the idea that we can replicate
regenerative ranching across the world
there would be nothing worse for the
ecosystem of wildlife that we need to
restore for Native ecosystems we're
talking Wetlands forests you can't
restore full force if you're doing
regenerative ranching 42 percent of
current grasslands used as pasture land
used to be forest or Woody Savannahs and
like I just want to ask are you
advocating for a reduction in meat and
dairy and animal sourced Foods or you
think that we can meet the current
demand in the increasing demand
I'm saying that I want to use my land to
its highest and best use in restarting
the cycles of Nature and someone else
could choose to make the same Choice
with plant regenerative articles that's
fine I support that but I won't be able
to use to follow my path which is
usually my animals to restart the cycles
of nature which again is my form of
rewilding I think it's a beautiful form
every wild it's an active incredible
arrogance for you to decide this study's
good this one's not this one suits me
this one did and I think it's an act of
incredible privilege for you to decide
how people who've been on the land all
their life should manage that land and
of what the people should eat that are
buying the production from because I'm
I'm Blown Away by that Arab that's
Improvement I just wanted to have some
some peer-reviewed scientific evidence
of these anecdotal claims that are made
I don't think that's coming from a place
of privilege I don't think that's coming
from a place of elitism there's an
abundance of research money going
towards justifying animal sourced Foods
in a number of different ways to claim
that grazing is is a solution there I
think there's a lot of complexity
missing from that statement and I think
that's used in a way to pull at the
heartstrings to justify this this
business that is destroying ecosystems
across the world I've compiled what what
I think is likely the largest database
on different reasons to ship to
plant-based diets this is not cherry
picking data this is a massive massive
library of the reasons why we should do
that
that was Jason Roundtree Will Harris
Nicholas Carter and Jimmy Vettel all
outspoken and passionate about
agriculture and the environment the
topic of how to feed upwards of 10
million people with the least amount of
deforestation and pollution is complex
and layered there's clearly big issues
within the standard industrial farming
system and in this conversation today's
guests get into what they believe is the
best way to farm and feed the world both
on a small and large scale Will Harris
is a fourth generation Cattleman who
tends the same land that his great
grandfather settled in in 1866 born and
raised at White Oak pastures will left
home to attend the University of Georgia
school of Agriculture where he was
trained in the industrial farming
methods after graduation him and his
father continued to raise cattle using
pesticides herbicides hormones and
antibiotics and fed their herd a high
carbohydrate diet of corn and soy in the
mid-1990s will became disenchanted with
the excesses of these industrialized
methods in 1995 he returned to the
farming method his great-grandfather had
used 130 years before using regenerative
farming methods will has since been
recognized all over the world as a
leader in environmental sustainability
he's the big director of the American
grass-fed Association and was selected
in 2011 as business person of the year
for Georgia by the small business
administration Jason Rountree is a
professor of animal science at Michigan
State University where he holds the
Charles Stewart bought distinguished
professorship for sustainable
agriculture roundtree's research focuses
on identifying the metrics and
management that reflects ecological
Improvement in grazing land and other
agricultural systems Rountree has given
presentations throughout the world and
has helped in the funding to conduct
food system research Jason is also the
co-director of the center for
regenerative agriculture at Michigan
State University his work in B
sustainability was featured in the movie
sacred cow and he too has been
highlighted in the Washington Post New
York Times Forbes and many other popular
media Publications Nicholas Carter is an
ecologist and co-founder of plant-based
data.org a library of pre-reviewed
Articles and summaries on the
environmental health economic and Zuna
disease evidence to shift to plant-based
diets he's been a panelist for the
center of biological diversity and a
speaker at the launch of the documentary
meet the future along with the Jane
Goodall Institute his thesis focused on
the global estimates of greenhouse gas
emissions attributed to animal
Agriculture and has since written
reports and articles on biodiversity
loss and Food Systems transitioning to
plant-based farming systems has also
been a focus where he's written about
regenerative plant farming practices
with a well-fed world he also has acted
as a scientific reviewer for the
best-selling book the proof is in the
plants by Simon Hill Jimmy vedel is a
farmer activist consultant and
researcher he has been a consultant
researcher and volunteer with the film's
conspiracy and what the health and the
animal protection party in Canada he
lives on a small-scale veganic farm in
Quebec and has been growing his own food
and homesteading for over 25 years and
became a professional full-time organic
farmer in 2005. he worked and consulted
on 11 organic and permaculture Farms
throughout Hawaii Mexico Central America
South America and Quebec he's the
co-founder of the North American veganic
certification standard certified veganic
whose mission is to certify Farmers
throughout North America and 100
plant-based agriculture principles and
practices and create a community that
works to end animal agriculture forever
in this episode they discuss the
differences between regenerative
ranching versus regenerative plant
agriculture analyzing them from the
lenses of what it improves on the
environmental metrics and also if it is
scalable we see where there is common
ground and where there are polarized
differences not sure the needle was
moved on either side but I appreciate
everyone's willingness and passion to
come together and discuss such an
important topic of our time so us
listeners can hear both sides of the
debate it definitely gets a little
heated but understandably so because of
the life's work that each of these
guests has put their heart and soul into
I found the conversation very riveting I
hope you enjoy it let's get into it
just quickly I've got a tip for you to
up your cleaning routine game you'll
save money and waste while using safe
sustainable and clean ingredients it's
Branch Basics they have non-toxic
cleaning products that I love using in
my home that are both effective and
hardworking these products are both
plant and mineral based and
biodegradable and I can safely use them
around my kids which is super important
to me and did you guys know that so much
of the cleaning products on the market
are largely filled with water so we
waste so much extra plastic when we
could just use Branch Basics that
supplies a bottle of concentrate one
bottle of concentrate makes three
all-purpose cleaners three bathroom
cleaners three streak free cleaners
three Foaming Hand washes and 64 loads
of laundry because you dilute the
concentrate with water in the reusable
bottles the concentrate is used in
different dilutions to create all of the
cleaning solutions then just refill the
bottles when you're out it's simple and
environmentally friendly so it is time
to replace your toxic cleaning products
because Branch basic sets you up for
success with their starter kit it comes
with the concentrate and the oxygen
boost which pairs with the concentrate
for an all natural way to tackle laundry
stains and grout and then it also comes
with the reusable bottles which comes in
both plastic and glass options the
all-purpose bottle the bathroom bottle
the streak free bottle the Foaming Hand
wash bottle and the laundry bottle so
use my code ln15 for 15 of all Branch
basic starter kits you'll be so happy
with the result and making the switch to
non-toxic and sustainable cleaning
products we're also brought to you by
safes leave I love my safe sleeve cell
phone case which protects from 5G EMF
radiation it comes in different colors
to suit your style and has slots for
your bank cards and cash which is so
convenient for me our electronic devices
play a huge role in our lives but all of
our personal electronic devices are
laptops cell phones and tablets emit
radiation an electronic radiation is
linked to adverse health effects even
the manufacturers know this because they
add warnings in the fine print safe
sleeve offers anti-radiation products
designed to give you the Peace of Mind
of knowing you and your devices are
protected while making them even easier
to use all of their anti-radiation
products incorporate lab tested
shielding technology that can block over
99 percent of RF and 92 percent of Elf
radiation there are very few
anti-radiation brands that offer lab
tested protection and theirs is publicly
available on their website and maybe
only one to two others that block elf
elf is much harder to block but equally
as important and all of their cell phone
cases provide military grade drop
protection which is also tested by a
third-party evaluator so if you've been
looking to get a case like this but have
been hesitating now is the time to get
it because I have a discount code for
you just click my link below in the show
notes and enter the code ln10 for 10 off
your order
all right let's get started welcome
everybody thank you so much for being
here today we're going to discuss how to
feed upwards of 10 billion people with
the least amount of deforestation
pollution Etc and also get into
eco-friendly ways of farming
regenerative ranching versus
regenerative plant agriculture analyzing
them from the lenses of what it improves
on the environmental metrics and also if
it's scalable I.E can this be put all
around the world so to get started can
you please make some opening statements
what you believe is the best type of
Agriculture to feed the world without
destroying the planet I'm gonna have
Jason you go first and then will and
then Nicholas and Jimmy
hello uh thank you for the question and
I think you posed a great a great
question Ellen in terms of
how do we look at the global complexity
of of feeding a population
and um I think the way that that I
focused my career the last 20 years in
this space is that I start locally and
work from the ground up
versus often we have these big large
debates from 10 or 20 000 people looking
down
and every environment every area in the
world has complexity their strengths and
weaknesses to the ecosystems that we all
work and function in there's important
uh social dynamics that enter into it as
well there's
uh communities that have evolved on on a
highly vegetable based diet there's
communities that have evolved on in a
pastoral 100 gallon setting
and
and so I think the way that that I I've
seen things work is
you know starting at that local place
and understanding that that really we
feed ourselves from the land
and and understanding in that context
how can we do it in a way that's most
ecologically and socially beneficial
and and so most of the areas I've worked
in throughout the world have been in
accommodation of plants and animals
working in an ecological way uh that not
only can provide helpful food but
likewise provide an ecological
resilience to a system
and that's the the lens I've taken great
well how about you the weather pastures
is my farm in Bluffton Georgia
I'm the fourth generation of my family
to manage the farm
my two daughters and the spouses of
management to tell you they're the fifth
generation and I have five grandchildren
who the sixth generation going up on the
farm right
in my lifetime I've seen the farm or if
under our ownership the farm has gone
full circle from a
system that was very focused on the land
the animals and the community
it was highly resilient
to being part of the industrialized
centralized commoditized production
system
which was very very hard on the land and
the animals and community and was not
Brazilian
and over the last 25 years moved back to
a model that most represents the the
earlier model here
I have seen with my own eyes and the
transition of how damaging the
industrial commodity system can be and
how healing this production model is
well look forward to talk to me more
about that
perfect thank you Nicholas how about you
so I I first want to thank everyone for
uh this conversation and for helping me
on uh I think there is a lot of
complexity to this topic and a lot of
nuance I also think that there is some
big picture realities that are important
to understand as we're looking at the
local system as well
so the WWF Brent Loken and others have
been quoted saying that the global food
production is a single largest human
pressure on Earth threatening local
ecosystems driving a a six mass
extinction impacting the stability of
the entire Earth system now this is the
food system as a whole obviously a lot
to that
but we have turned a lot of the earth
into Farms fifty percent of all
habitable land and this isn't done
evenly over 75 percent of all
agricultural land is for animal
agriculture that returns back about 18
of global calories or about 37 percent
of protein
and if you're looking at Beef
specifically obviously a lot of spectrum
to it and we can talk about that today
but 60 of all agricultural land is used
for beef cattle and that only accounts
back for about two percent of calories
or five percent of global protein
so what has this kind of resulted in
this has resulted in
Mass wildlife collapse over time there's
other areas of course that have called
cause biodiversity issues but right now
wild mammals make up only four percent
of global biomass
and you know if you look at like humans
and domesticated animals as a whole it's
30 times as much as wild mammals so this
is a significant crisis and there is
Solutions here and there is kind of some
complexity in dealing with this but I
think it's important to acknowledge some
of these realities
okay thank you Nicholas Jimmy how about
you well first of all yes Ellen thank
you so much for hosting this debate and
Will and Jason and Nicholas uh thank you
all this is this is going to be a lot of
fun today uh so I've been fortunate and
blessed to
realize that it was really really
important to grow my own food and I
started that 25 years ago
18 years ago I became a professional
farmer and that was in northern Arizona
uh where the land that we had purchased
had been fenced off for 10 years but was
completely still completely overgrazed
it was a 640 hectare uh section of land
or 640 acre section of land that uh was
completely denuded of all Native flora
and it was and so and it is interesting
talking about these complexities because
in Arizona the the cow manure would not
blend into the soil it would just sit
and dry as a as a dry patio we had my
first wife and I had this brilliant idea
that we would pick up all the patties
and manure reconstitute it and then use
it uh to plant it and that's and that's
what we did we thought it would make
sense
it didn't work all that well but we
continue on so uh I became a
professional farmer 18 years ago in
Arizona I became an organic farmer uh
after that farm of five years I was
lucky to be able to travel around uh
Hawaii Mexico Belize Costa Rica Panama
Ecuador Colombia and into Quebec and
work and volunteer and consult on a
small scale uh organic even conventional
and some veganic permaculture Farms and
this is what I noticed from around the
world that the best models were the
smallest models and this was actually
proven also in a un report that's at 80
percent of all Farms worldwide Are
Family Farms five hectares and less
so the world model the world scale model
is very very small it's only in the
United States and Canada where we have
these massive Farms Canada actually has
the largest farm uh per largest acreage
of farm per Farm in the world with U.S
number two and it's the only reason that
we look at these models as being bigger
is better but it's not it's more
wasteful it's worse for the environment
it's worse ecologically thankfully in
2014 I I made the transition over to
veganic Growing veganic farming it's
still very small scale we're only a half
an acre Farm five acres is completely
left to rewild
and what I've learned is that by using
just plants to grow plants
we can increase soil organic matter we
can increase soil organic carbon and we
can increase the amount of carbon
sequestration we have okay thank you
Jimmy all right so now I want to get to
uh where I think we find common ground
and you guys find alignment and I'm
gonna make a few statements and with
each statement please let me know if you
guys agree so that helps us know moving
forward hey at least we align and you
guys align on this particular these
particular topics so the first one is
factory farming in our current food
system is flawed do you guys agree with
that one
yes everyone agree you can make you
could say it out loud yeah
what about you I think all agriculture
has swallows right okay cool all right
the next one is we are in a climate and
biodiversity crisis
yes do you agree yes yes
the next one is food prices and food
insecurity is increasing
yeah you agree
I think food prices
um I think it's a variable question
based on where we are globally
and as well as with food security but I
don't think that's a blanket statement
we can make
oh okay okay do you want to expand a
little bit on that no I I think if you
look at the for instance in the United
States it's an example I think we have a
very
a very um solid food supply that is that
is definitely
um inexpensive and so I think that
there's always pockets and food deserts
and challenges anywhere you go but I I
think that's a a pretty tough one just
to make on a on a big basis that way I
think it's a very nuanced um
answered I agree I agree with that too
yeah yeah I think that's a that's a good
kind of nuanced response to that okay
perfect all right and then lastly
different types of conservation
agriculture
um that I think you all both are in
support of which is no-till composting
cover crops and reducing fertilizers is
that true yes I think we're all pursuant
little principles okay great all right
is there any more that you guys think
that I didn't cover here on what you
guys might agree with today or do you
feel like that covers it pretty well
I feel like we all probably understand
that ecological
approaches to to farming are very
important okay so I'm gonna move on now
and let's get into the debate for those
who are listening and watching this
debate it's going to be mostly between
Nicholas and Jason and then will Harris
the Rancher and Jimmy the veganic farmer
are gonna chime in here and there as it
suits
so for the first question this is
supposed to both of you but I'm gonna
have J uh Nicholas you go first what is
the big picture situation with food and
the environment based on the scientific
literature today
I think that's a very complex question I
think we can answer it many ways
throughout
this uh conversation but I think uh
ultimately
there's a number of issues with our food
system uh it uses a lot of land
it's not necessarily the most efficient
and we really need to make some
decisions very soon because
uh the Western diet the diet you know
typically in in richer countries
is being exported
to Growing populations poor regions as
they become medium income as they become
High income and that in turn is going to
come with a lot of pressures on Earth
pressures on planetary boundaries
pressures on land biodiversity
deforestation
and when we're looking at a number of
these factors
even if it's soil uh natural untouched
or even re-wilded areas
provide a number of the benefits that we
want
so we need to look at this situation
okay how do we produce food
ecologically
without using an extreme amount of land
how do we produce back a good amount of
nutrients and proteins and in calories
in ways that can also provide economic
in in livelihoods to to people working
at this
so I think ultimately
I would sum it up as this is very
important right now because we have a
choice to make
if we shift to plant-based diets uh in
rich countries especially this is the
focus uh we could free up about 3
billion hectares of land and with that
land we could restore a lot of
biodiversity and there's been studies
that shows we could draw down the
equivalent of 9 to 16 years of current
Fossil fuel emissions that's from a
study in in nature from from Matthew
Hayek and others
but if nothing is done
in the global adoption of this Western
diet you know G20 food consumption
patterns by 2050 we would exceed
planetary boundaries in a number of ways
greenhouse gases it shows we'd increase
it by 263 percent
and for land that this is just a typical
food system right now if that's exported
we would require up to seven Earths and
again this is a study that is from a
number of quality researchers uh Brent
Loken Willett springman Jonathan Foley
and this does not consider regenerative
ranching which you're going to get into
right that would use far far more land
than the typical food system so I think
this kind of sets the stage I think in
in my analysis of the research of the
decisions we need to make all right
Jason you can reply to him sure yeah and
um
you know I I think again
first of all um
is is we look at management of land and
I've had the opportunity to work
globally uh in food production systems
and I've worked with
um the Maasai I've worked with
you know all all sorts of different
cultures
and um
you know having these topical debates on
on how we treat land
is is just that and I think the fact is
is that every culture is different how
we do things are different
um and so when it when it comes to land
and how we work in the future
is that there's people that are in the
Ecology of that land and not above it
they're not separate from it and so when
we talk about these concepts of
rewilding there's always people in the
land on the land and of the land
that's something that's come from from
indigenous cultures it's who we are
today
and therefore I I think the more
plausible way perhaps of moving forward
is focusing on how we manage the land
and and how we look at embracing
biodiversity as a component of
regenerative agriculture
and I I think simultaneously regardless
if we look at the output of a protein
whether it be plant-based or
animal-based that the most important
thing we can do is consider how we
manage those systems because no matter
how you how you work it you're always
going to have unintended consequences
it's often difficult to assess with
those unintended consequences look like
and I think the fact is that if we take
the science and respect Nick the guys
that you talk about
that you know these are often these
large Global assessments but at the end
of the day it's farmers and ranchers and
people in local communities that feed
themselves and that feed that feed their
communities and elsewhere
and so
um I I have a heart for biodiversity I
have a heart for for for wildlife I I
have a heart for all those things
um it's just the lens that I've come
through is very different and it's it's
one that that really is trying to work
with how we manage to get the best
outcomes we can based on on who owns the
land who's on the land and how it's
managed and so maybe just a different
lens that I look at it through
you can go ahead and reply Nicholas if
you would like to
yeah I mean I agree with a lot of that
as well I think
um these are complex systems decisions
should not be made without analysis of
the socioeconomic challenges that come
with all this
um you know when it comes to rewilding
people should be benefited
significantly for rewilding
um you know and that's kind of happening
in some areas across the world there is
carbon Credit Systems that are starting
to look at the science-based ways to
draw down carbon there should be more in
terms of enhancing native biodiversity
not just a little bit of biodiversity
but significant amounts of land for wild
animals to travel and go from different
ecosystems where they were before
including carnivores including native
ruminants where they should be so I
think this is all something that is
complex but there needs to be incentives
for people that own this land to to do
this otherwise I totally get it this is
not necessarily going to happen
oh
I think that that Nicholas and I are in
agreement in our feelings about
rewilding
you know I I really believe that the
industrial agricultural model that I
used to be part of
is is part of the the destruction of uh
extinct a species were driven into
Extinction uh non-native invasives have
been brought in I'm I I really want to
see my father rewild it and I think I
have rewilded it
oh I collect the wood
what Nicholas and I were part of me is
because I am experienced in this I know
if I just fenced my phone off
and said I'm going to let it evolve and
go back to the pre-columbian ecosystem
that it was
it wouldn't happen
the pre-columbian ecosystem had a lot of
elk and wood spice and
oldest land
uh and it didn't have invasive species
like Privet Hedge and Kudzu all this
land
if if I left if I fenced this Farm off
and left it for a century or two or
three it would not look like the
pre-columbian we have changed we have
done too much to change the environment
uh I my rewilding and it's very
important to me Mary Wilding is
restarting the cycles of nature
restarting the mineral cycle microbial
cycle carbon cycle water cycle energy
cycle restart these things
you know I I actively am involved in
this biomimicry this emulation of nature
and it is a very imperfect emulation of
Glacier I would not claim otherwise
but it is probably a lot more similar to
the pre-columbian
ecosystem that it would be if I just
fenced it off with no large remnants
and many many species that should that
used to be here should have been here
we're here during the first evolution
we're not here anymore in species that
weren't supposed to be here are now here
and you know one of the ancient Greeks
said for every pestilence that makes
your sins she sends the Cure
and we have brought pestilences over I
can name you a lot of them and we can
bring two we didn't bring the natural
control system
and my form of rewilding respectfully I
think is a lot more uh efficacious than
beneficial than
systems I've seen happening
[Music]
all right guys I have to tell you about
the Apothecary anema Mundi herbals which
carries organic wild crafted and
ethically grown Botanicals every vibrant
and medically potent remedy is packaged
in eco-friendly packaging of recyclable
glass or biodegradable bags once you
shop their site you'll see what I mean
there are so many incredible goodies to
get but if you get just one thing you've
got to get their collagen beauty kit
which is full of plant magic to help
support healthy hair skin nails and
Bones this kit includes a dirty Rose
chai collagen which contains herbs known
for their collagen protecting and
boosting effects it also comes with
their super fruit collagen their
signature formula composed of collagen
boosting plants enhanced with the
beautifying powers of superfoods you
also get an original collagen booster
powder a plant-based blend that's the
ultimate Beauty boost with adaptogens
ancient herbs and flowers to support
radiant hair glowing skin and healthy
nails and lastly it comes with a
collagen face oil and rose quartz guasa
the perfect addition which feels Divine
on my skin it would be an amazing gift
to give a love one but if not for
someone special in your life at least
get it for yourself and anema Moody
herbals uses Fair Trade Practices Beyond
organic farming education and small
farmers to create remedies that benefit
people from all walks of life so use my
code Ellen 20 for 20 off just click the
link in my show notes to get this deal
I really absolutely agree and if you
look at pre-columbian times pre-colonial
times of the ways say bison Rome you
know they they they ran all the way from
the prairies
in the summertime all the way down south
to Texas and east to west now I don't
know how far east and west I don't think
they came all the way to as far as the
deserts in Arizona for sure they went
all the way to Georgia
um I'm not so sure I don't know if they
went all the way to the coast but you're
talking about a large swath of land so I
absolutely agree with that in that Realm
of the United States and Canada where
those bison were theoretically you could
re-graze that entire area
from north to south with cows if they
were to follow the exact
same
pattern where basically they would go
from north to south 2 000 miles or so
every single year and back but we don't
do that with our grazing systems but
that is a very interesting point that it
could be done that way
the problem that I I unders I foresee
with raising animals and raising cows in
this way is that
they're not living their entire lives
they're only living 20 months 30 months
whereas wood bison at the time I think
they could live up to almost 30 years
old
plus there were predators involved in
the circulation of those Buffalo and
First Nations people also that were
taking what they needed to survive
but then take it a little bit further
and this is all again comes to the
complexities of region in Arizona where
I was there probably weren't any wood
bison but there were other
there were other animals
there were there are mule deer there are
pronghorn antelope there are others
and here in Quebec there absolutely were
no wood bison so how we rewild here
is completely different than what would
say would happen in Georgia or where
those Buffalo would go and this is
exactly the type of complexes we can
look at and I think when we look at the
global perspective
we still I still come back down to the
fact that I believe we can do this by
just incorporating cover crops and
plants versus raising those animals and
their subsequent
harvesting or slaughtering of those
animals
yeah I think you know Jimmy I agree with
a lot and I think that
the way I've looked at it is you know I
I think there are systems I've seen
globally
that
you know are where we are in history and
in in the process of our food system
and that you know managers work very
diligently to mimic as much as they can
natural processes
um there are many others that don't
that I think absolutely have managed in
a way with respect to grazing livestock
that have degraded the land I've seen it
globally
I've seen massive complexities that
interface uh the mismanagement of
grazing livestock and migrating will to
be specific example or others right
and and so
you know I don't disagree I think with
the fact that in a perfect world if we
could do something a certain way we
could look at it this way
you know I think maybe in My Lens I've
just you know I feel like the the
pragmatic approach now
is to really work to try to mimic these
natural processes
where people are in their in their given
management system right in in that way
and um and that's you know something
I've watched will do where you know he's
got all these multiple species of
livestock birds and other things where
it says is you know unique of a mimic
type of Savannah as you might see
um and and so I I think that we probably
agree you know with a lot of those
things the other thing you know Nick I
was curious what your thoughts are is
that like the areas when you look in
Australia or in Africa or down in Texas
in other areas California another
example
is that like when we when we relieve
grazing pressure in some of these
systems the first thing that typically
happens is we have all this wood Woody
brush encroachment
and I just remember working with the
Messiah on the mara and listening to a
friend there that was a guy saying you
know talking about his his you know
Elders saying you know it used to be so
much more open right when you had the
megaplana that was that was opening it
up
and now you know with with a a lack of
of animal pressure in those systems the
first thing that happens is all this
brush encroaches
and that lends to Fire and things and
I'm just curious like in your mind if
you were to transition to this rewilding
like what does that look like because we
see the problems in California I've seen
them in Australia African other areas
yeah no thanks that's a good question
and um I think it's complex but I think
in areas that had these native animals
before helping the ecosystem we should
be looking to return them obviously
easier said than done not always a
perfect scenario where that's possible
but in looking at the meta-analyzes that
look at what happens when you remove
grazing pressure
it's pretty damn good in terms of what
it does for increasing not only plant
diversity but animal diversity this was
a recent study of the University of
Alberta that looked at 109 different
studies and it was in many different
countries many different regions and
we're not talking like short-term like a
couple years what happens we're talking
like after an amount of time
um you know 10 plus years of areas
rewilded areas protected to have as best
as possible the native ecosystem that
was there before you're going to have a
much better ecosystem with by
biodiversity more carbon drawdown
and um
yeah I think that's what we should be
striving for
and you know in terms of getting there I
get it there's some difficulties in in
getting there but um
I mean in most cases
cattle are invasive cattle are not
they're not native to these areas where
they're grazing so yes you can attempt
to to mimic it in some situations and
certainly there's a major Spectrum in
terms of of grazing which we can we can
of course talk about
but I don't see how we can restore some
of the Key Stone species like carnivores
into ecosystems that
would be pasture line I don't I don't
see how that can happen so when in a
real wildly situation you of course can
do that and we need to do that we need
to protect Lynn so like I'll just end it
there on the last point there like the
biodiversity Summit that just happened
in Montreal in December of 2022 they're
looking at protecting 30 percent of land
by 2030 and 30 of ocean
it really should be more than that but
like we're not even close to that now uh
and we need to for many reasons so we
should be looking at rewilding land and
the most logical area to get this from
is those massive massive areas of lands
that are overgrazed
Nicholas your statement was you don't
see how that can be done
and I know you can't but if you'll come
see me I'll show you I'll show you I'll
show you land that has not been grazed
for decades I've acquired land in the
last 10 years
that I've never seen ruminants on it
other than fear I've never seen cattle
she goes on it and it's a jungle It's a
Jungle of non-native invasives that is
so important
non-native invasive
they're here now and and Pandora's out
of the box so
you know I mean we can't reintroduce
wood spices we've driven them into
Extinction
but I I admittedly cattle are not native
to North America admitted but neither
are these invasives that were battling
my land that I have been grazing looks a
heck of a lot more like I believe
pre-columbian
Coastal plane looked and land that has
just been left
ungrazed no animal impact on what's an
awful for
I'm 68 years old and for at least my
lifetime probably well yeah I mean I
think uh a lot of that is true a lot of
that I agree with will uh how how do we
um scale this how do we like in terms of
feeding the world
I mean we can get into this but um yeah
the scalability of this system this is a
very important topic and um
yeah what's your thoughts what's your
thoughts on the scalability of your
system okay so scaling it and and
feeding the world
the stuff you brought up
and I want to admit to you that my
system here is not super scalable it is
not it may be as big as it needs to be
quite as fast as it may be as big as it
needs to be but it is highly
replicatable
what we've done here has been with a c
student with Bank debt financing is
highly replicatable it can be done over
and over again every ecosystem is there
and every economy is different so you
wouldn't emulate what we do exactly
but this sort of focus on restarting the
cycles of nature which is my version of
rewilding is highly replicated
the other thing I would challenge is
uh I agree I agree with what you said
about feeding people but the assertions
seem to be that land is the limiting
factor
and I would suggest to you that land is
a limiting factor not the limiting fact
I'm not sure we won't run out of a lot
of other with industrial commodity
farming a lot of a lot of other uh
resources before we run out of land we
we can run out of land I I admitted we
can also run out of water
pure water good water we can run out of
these reductive fertilizers we're in the
cream room all that but there's a
there's a lot of things we will probably
run out of before we run out of land
do the do you have Ellen do you have
that link of that broken water system I
think Jenny sent you yeah it doesn't
need to be played now at some point
during this during this interaction I
want to I want that that's kind of a mic
drop moment but and I got a question
from Nicholas this is a question this is
not part of my response
Nicholas the the
plant
based diet that you advocate
is it the solar farming that that Jimmy
Advocates with Farmers raising
vegetables small farmers individually
raising vegetables for the local market
or is it big fields of peas and soy for
plant-based protein because big fields
of soy and and uh peas are going to look
just like this industrial farming we've
got going on right now corn cotton peach
okay yeah so good question I first want
to respond to what you mentioned before
about replicability and scalability
ability and then I'll answer that
because that's a great question so uh I
mean we have research on land of course
there's other metrics as well other
planetary boundaries that their food
system is gonna gonna affect uh in
almost every case a shifted plant-based
diets even if it's a more industrial
intensive plant-based diet would still
be better and I can show evidence for
for showing that but just in terms of
land just to end on that point there
perhaps that'll come back in the
conversation but uh study out of uh
Harvard and Boston University 2018
showed that if the U.S wanted to match
the current factory firm beef to
grass-fed
and not alter beef consumption is a key
part USB production would require 63 to
7 270 percent more land and that's like
a grass finish system that's not uh the
regenerative agriculture system the
regenerative wrenching that uh I mean as
your study showed Jason would use two
times more land than that so I think
land is a big part of this discussion
and um
to your other point uh I advocate as
much as possible for uh veganic
Agriculture and I'm not naive that there
isn't challenges to that and maybe we'll
let Jimmy talk to that at some point in
this conversation but uh I think the
scalability of veganic farming is far
far easier and accomplishable than uh
regenerative agriculture as it's
currently defined
so uh I think there's a few ways you can
do that and some of it is very logical
we have a huge food waste issue globally
I think something like 30 of all food is
is wasted
yeah it's high of course so uh with that
food race there's ways to repurpose that
there's ways to integrate that with uh
vegetation native vegetation that's
growing and create some high quality
compost which could be used of course in
veganic for me I'm sure you use lots of
compost as well in your system well so
this is a way that we can scale this up
in a way that is ideal you know like to
the last point about your kind of
commodity crops
let's not forget that 50 of all
commodity crops right now are for
confined animals so I think we're in
agreement that factory farming system
needs to end but I don't hear any
regenerative ranchers saying we need a
massive decrease in meat consumption
because if that was the case I probably
wouldn't be talking much about this
stuff
but when that's not part of the
conversation and instead we're talking
about kind of this like carbon negative
beef or that we need to replicate this
across the world I call BS
yeah so just some thoughts and I didn't
know Jimmy did you want to follow up
first I know that he had asked you about
some things on that
yeah I'm just going to say that I
absolutely agree uh uh a monoculture
corn or soy field is about as biodiverse
as a parking line so you know it's it is
the two biggest crops grown in the
United States today by acreage is corn
and soy followed by wheat and and like
Nicholas said the vast majority goes to
animal agriculture or in Corn's case
also to fuel or elf ethanol so and
what's even more disturbing I find
really really disturbing is that we're
exporting our land to Saudi Arabia to
China to Europe to South America with
selling these soy the soy in this corn
for them to raise animals
so because they can't grow those crops
there because they're too dry but they
still have decided to confine and raise
animals so me I find this probably the
most shocking of it all that in the
United States and Canada we are letting
our farmlands be sold away whereas we
can be using this to feed and somebody
talked about food insecurity it is a big
problem in the United States and Canada
one out of eight families
every single day may not get a
nutritious meal every single day in the
United States and Canada so yes it's
complex but is also extremely real and
of course it does fall apart poverty
lines in Arizona I was in one of the
poorest counties in the United States
Navajo County uh and we were talking a
55 to 60 percent unemployment rate
the food insecurity there was
astronomical so that is a very real
problem as well
so um a few things right
um Nick and challenges I have with a lot
of the research you cited
is that none of these
papers they never factor in what's
happening with soil carbon
they haven't factored in the fact that
we've lost over half our topsoil in the
same cropping systems in the last you
know since the Green Revolution right
and and so number one I think that if
you look at the main influencer of a
carbon footprint in any system it's the
amount of soil carbon that we've lost it
isn't methane it isn't nitrous it's soil
carbon and I think that it's it's a bit
of an easy out for the plant-based
argument to say we need more of this
when the land that he's actually
regenerating that you're accusing him
that takes twice the land is trying to
repair what it what a crop system that
you're advocating started in the first
place and I just I don't find that to be
a plausible argument secondly today's
corn crop in the United States only 35
percent of the corn crop in the U.S
actually doing the livestock anymore of
that maybe half bill in the cattle the
number one areas now that we see
two-thirds of it are going into corn
syrup they're going into corn oil uh and
they're going into ethanol and the
distillers or the byproduct of that is
actually built into that to that number
and and so things have changed I mean we
can also look at at intake data I mean
you look at the last 200 years saturated
animal fat intake has decreased 70
percent while in that same vein we've
seen a linear increase in calories from
oils from soybean
and and so the fact is is that we're
eating considerably less animal fats
today than we have for a very long
period of time uh we've seen very
negative impacts on health since the
1980s and and I think just you know
blindly pointing to animal fat or
animals is that problem uh we know it's
processed food right we all agree we
need to eat real food but but the fact
then is that you know on so many of the
Acres that we have today is that
management doesn't get taken into any of
this data or any of the meta policies
and and I think that there is a lot of
complexity in that that we just
blanketly do meta-analysis over the
world
and and the fact is is that you know
we've we've done a lot of work at Will's
place in measuring it and you know I I'd
like to to understand why you you want
to debunk the work that he's done and I
mean I don't necessarily appreciate the
fact that you're putting out all this
media and you never call me right like
I'd have been happy to talk to you about
the work we did or the challenges we
might have had I mean I'm sure we could
probably get along
um but but I just like to know where
you're coming from because there there
seems to be some some areas in the
arguments that that are leading us right
into this negative eroded landscape that
would try to regenerate
okay I'm gonna let you reply Nicholas
and then I want to move on to the next
question
there's a number of things I want to
reply to first uh the the comment about
processed foods generally yes I advocate
for a whole food plant-based diet but to
say all processed food is bad I think
that's a very blanket statement that
lacks complexity uh tofu technically is
processed it's an incredibly healthy
healthy food process
yeah
okay okay yeah okay so you're talking
about Ultra process in this case now I
think there's a number of Health
arguments that could be made there but I
don't think any of us here are experts
in that to make that I think that's
another conversation
um in terms of soil Health uh I guess
first I'll answer where am I coming from
I'm coming from an appreciation of
nature I'm an ecologist I I study uh
forests and ecosystems and wetlands and
I've got years of experience with
conservation organizations uh across
Canada uh in climate science
organizations across Canada and
nature-based solutions is a big part of
my work so one of the biggest drivers of
nature collapse is ranching now I'm not
like I'm in no way trying to like debunk
Will Harris is firm that's not that's
not my Approach that's not my my style I
explore these ideas and I comment on
them because I'm seeing evidence on it
I'm seeing peer-reviewed scientific
evidence and when it comes to soil you
mentioned soil
uh Rattan Lao one of the most respected
soil scientists in the world
shows that yeah of course so I mean he's
got a number of studies which I'm sure
you're familiar with this shows overall
of course this is a blanket statement
but agricultural soils store 25 to 75
percent less soil organic carbon
right then native untouched ecosystems
even rewilded ecosystems will store more
carbon and we're not talking just in
soil we're talking also above soil also
trees that don't have that same soil
carbon saturation so I could post some
questions back but I'm sure there's
other questions we get into but I'd like
to get into solar carbon saturation and
how come it's not really reflected a
whole lot in your studies and I'm not
asking this question in like a an
attacking way I'm generally curious why
from your take the soil carbon
saturation is not factored in because
we've seen time and time again there's
there's a number of studies that show
eventually soil saturate especially on
agricultural land it can be time limited
and easily reversible so I don't even
hold a whole lot of weight in that soil
argument that that's like a thing to
necessarily lean on but I'd be curious
to know your thoughts you bet yeah so I
work a lot with Francesca catrupo who is
a World's lead she's a a collaborator
she and I are working on a 20 million
dollar Grant throughout the United
States on looking at the metrics of soil
carbon and the fact of the matter is is
that I mean to me saturation is such a
red here in the debate and primarily
because the majority of the data when
you look at soil saturation there's
there's
basically the aspect of microbial you
know Associated mineral Associated
organic matter that's microbial
facilitated and the fact is is that it
takes 10 to 12 percent organic matter
and a majority of our soils before we
see saturation in in the mineral and the
fact of the matter is if you look at the
soils that we see in grazing systems and
agriculture most of will soils that
we've measured are in a three to five
percent range a majority of the cropland
acres are at or below one percent so the
fact of the matter is is we're not going
to see saturation for decades upon
decades upon decades
um and even then we also know that there
is a linear uh growth of uh you know
basically the Palm or the particular
organic matter it's more labile Granite
it's organic matter that we see more
enforested environments uh the final
thing I'll also say in respect to that
is often these saturation debates are
only happening in the topsoil uh just
only recently or we start starting to go
down to meter deep or even 1.2 meters in
terms of measuring overall management
impacts on soil carbon and what we're
learning is that even in the 50
centimeters down to 1.2 centimeters
there's a lot of things going on down
there
um you might want to point Nick to the
Roth instead study and the Rothman said
study does show saturation but I'd also
like to say if that study was done on
hectare plots and in terms of their
grazing they didn't even graze livestock
they mow it and they put out manure so
here we are doing soil saturation work
where we're trying to mimic a grazing
event and we're using that to prop up
Global arguments in terms of saturation
and so the fact is is that yes can we
see saturation absolutely but only in
very very high concentrations of soil
organic matter and in the systems we see
today we are so far away from that
happening I don't even think it needs to
be part of the debate today so you're
talking like 20 to 30 years
no further than that because the fact
that the rate of organic matter it's
going to be considerably higher
um and and I've even talked about it in
in some studies that we might expect it
to happen in 20 to 30 years
and and more than not it's often just to
to make a statement that I put it into a
paper right to you know talk about the
reviewers but the point is that
um I I would love to send you the
article Francesca put together in uh I
believe it's in nature on this and the
fact is it's going to take a
considerable amount of time I mean I I
hope man look I'll say this Nick if we
could if we could get 10 to 12 organic
matter in our AG soils in 30 years I'll
retire and call it a career because that
that's the volume of soil carbon it
would take to saturate it okay how are
you offsetting the methane
okay excuse me are you are you offset
are you offsetting the methane in this
case so if we're gonna do this by
grazing are you going to offset the
methane that's being emitted yeah I mean
I mean look at I mean it's been
happening for
millions of years
okay number one and I think we've had
ruminants on Earth since what 56 million
years ago and we've had methane cycling
in those systems but we have 4 billion
now
yeah but but if you look at the the
research let's say in North America I
mean pre-colonial ruminants there's more
megaphone than than there is today you
look at the work in Africa there's more
megafauna there now what I will grant is
that there are different places and
they're managed differently
um but I think from a standpoint of
looking at overall methane our work has
shown that time and time again we can't
offset methane in fact where I was
working in Australia the Australian
national government actually has
emission baselines for all of their
ranches and their monetizing soil carbon
under the auspice that ranchers must be
able to offset the methane emission
which is happening in in several land
bases in Australia today with government
regulated monitoring and so the fact is
is that can methane be a problem in
ruminant systems I will say absolutely
yes but I think simultaneously with
management and what I've seen producers
do throughout the world it's something
that can definitely be offset and it's a
natural biogenic cycle that's been
happening for a very long period of time
okay um this is all super fascinating
and thanks for everything you're sharing
I want to move on to another question
though just to break it down for those
who are listening to this Jason or uh
yes uh Jason can you please explain what
is regenerative agriculture for both
plant and animal farming yeah right
well I think I I always think of plants
and animals in synchrony together but
regenerative agriculture to me is
effectively the emphasis of soil Health
principles in agriculture uh at work and
talk about soil Health principles we
talk about minimizing disruption we talk
about perennialization or keeping grain
plants growing and Roots growing for as
long as possible in the system uh adding
microbial biodiversity into those
systems getting animals back into our
our grazing systems
um Etc
and the fact is is that
um I don't believe regenerative AG is a
qualitative metric either you are or
you're not I think that no matter where
anybody is in agriculture whether you're
a big scale AG or small AG there is room
to implement soil Hill principles that
can help regenerate the Ecology of those
systems and and and everybody's on a
gradient of where they are in life and I
think that's the way that I try to
approach it so I'm not isolating a crop
farmer or an animal farmer or a big
farmer little farmer but more than not
looking at the principles that lead to
regenerative and ecological outcomes
great and uh Nicholas do you want to
reply to that or Jimmy as well and then
I have another question so before we get
into it too much
yeah I mean uh regenerative agriculture
has largely not been defined very well
uh there's a there's a big variance in
terms of what people think it is of
course it's one of those terms right
that is replacing older terms and you
know typically of course involves
improving soil Health increasing some
biodiversity
um you know reducing erosion integrating
usually compost uh cover crops no-till
but like you know I think regenerative
agriculture should be more than that it
should be also what can free up land for
Native biodiversity like in a
significant way not just a little bit
more biodiversity in the soil but uh
native animals back to where they should
be from before and I think that's
entirely possible and I think
regenerative agriculture should uh net
sequester more methane than is emitted
and we can come back to that methane
topic because I don't buy at all the
evidence that there's firms all across
the world that's offsetting their
methane cattle ranches across the board
are net emitting more methane than is
being drawn down and there's abundance
of data showing that
yeah do you want to reply to that go
ahead
yeah oh I'd like to find regular tobacco
filter for you yeah go ahead uh I was in
as a as an industrial farmer
uh
my yeah every day I looked for
technology to kill some perceived pests
that was in my monocultural system
that was that was the the it actually
defined a good industrial farmer is spot
the pest whether it be microbial
Animal Adventure vegetation whatever
fungus and and kill it use technology to
kill it fast forward to the last 20
years I've been farming in a model that
I consider to be regenerative
and it is the opposite of the industrial
system I my goal today is to create life
more life more species more diversity
uh
the industrial model breaks the cycles
of nature that I listed for you before
my goal today is to restart the
Disciples of nature
what I do to be a really good form of
rewild
okay
um what about you Jimmy is there
something you want to say about what
regenerative agriculture is yeah from
what I've seen there's
and from what I've researched so there's
regenerative agriculture with with
relation to animals alone or grazing
with the idea that there are uh plants
being grown that the animals then graze
on then there's regenerative agriculture
which is kind of kind of an organic
agriculture system where we're trying to
produce more biodiversity of plants
within our cropping systems but also
uses a vast amount of say off-farm
manures or in an organic system and then
there's the system that I was lucky to
jump upon which is the veganic
agriculture system and
what we're doing is we're everything
completely comes full circle so we'll
grow the plant we'll let the plant grow
up we'll Harvest what we can so let's
just take broccoli for example we'll
harvest the head of broccoli the rest of
the plant then decomposes back into the
bed so is there there's almost no all
the carbon that we were taking out which
is the broccoli we're then leaving the
entire plant to sit back onto the bed
in addition to that in our particular
system we underseed with with cover
crops so we'll underseed with say Clover
and this is something that bigger
veganic agriculture models are I just
certified uh I I'm I'm the co-founder of
a certification a new certification in
North America called certified veganic
and I just certified a 400 acre soybean
rye and
and popcorn farm and now this is in that
idea that oh that's that big monoculture
and I'm the same way I'm like whoa
that's too big I don't want that that's
that's crazy
but what he's doing in this particular
Farm is he's under seeding with cover
crops while he's planting his soybeans
while he's planting his popcorn while
he's planting so his soil organic matter
has gone up in just three years from say
4.4 percent to 5.1 percent because it's
a no-till system where he's just
incorporating the cover crops just in a
plant-based system no animals at all
so a regenerative system the
conversation or regenerative is fine
but I believe that it really must be one
that is 100 plant-based and if we want
to graze animals because we'd feel like
in certain areas this is possible again
we can do that in a Management Facility
but we just don't kill them we don't
take them off the land unfortunately a
White Oaks pastor and and I have to say
well that your model your grazing model
is quite impressive and I've read your
I've read it and I used to be an animal
raiser back in Arizona I raise goats I
raise chickens for their eggs I raise
goats for their milk so I get it
but
98.5 of the animals that you raise are
Broiler chickens that are eight to ten
weeks old and then killed I don't
understand how that works in the grazing
principle we're talking about we're
talking all this about beef
but yet 98.5 percent of the animals that
are slaughtered on your farm every year
are Broiler chickens that only live
eight to ten weeks and if they're
anything like the organic chickens I saw
they can't even stand up anymore
by the time they're being slaughtered
because they are genetically bred to be
so heavy that their little legs cannot
support them anymore and this is just
undue suffering It's just sad
go ahead will once you replied to that
well
so I would suggesting you look at in
terms of measuring volume pounds not a
number of head
on your farm right
or 45 percent
chicken or
no
the inventory today would be uh about 3
000 head of cattle as close and probably
uh
yeah I got I got this chicken and some
cows
that
when you you actually listed all the
animals from the study that you put out
and 98.5 of the animals were boiler
chicken we have balanced lies the public
business dramatically and increase
that study
yeah it's changed dramatically and um
okay so that was an unsustainable system
is what you're saying
I didn't say that but I made the
business decision to change the mix
okay okay all right so I have a question
then
um for Nicholas and then uh Will and
Jason you guys can reply if you'd like
to what's the state of Regulation and
accountability within the regenerative
label okay so for for me in terms of the
the state of Regulation it's um there's
very little I mean people can call their
firm as regenerative uh and Market it
that way and this has caused you know a
number of green water green washing
situations where consumers are not
necessarily aware now in The Wider
situation like the food system as a
whole lacks a lot of transparency we
don't know where crop necessarily come
from we don't know where food comes from
in the grocery store this is an issue of
course but when it comes to uh kind of
very strong bold claims about carbon
negative beef regenerative uh beef
there's not much regulation and even if
you look at like the Farms that are
plotted across North America on various
Maps regenerative International has a
map of firms and uh you can look at some
of the maps that are plotted on that map
and they're actually intensive feedlots
so uh you know that's just obviously
deceiving to customers is deceiving to
everyone
but then you can also like just input
yourself on that firm and people have
done this and um You can call yourself
regenerative even though it's not even a
functioning firm so that's a major issue
and I think
one thing that's worth mentioning that I
think would be open to discussion for uh
you Jason and will would be I still see
whether pastures beef as marketed as
carbon negative yet the study that you
did Jason showed it wasn't the original
Qantas study of course showed it was
but then the updated study showed it was
not
um sequestering more carbon in the
ground than the methane that was emitted
so I kind of want to know like is it
carbon negative beef or not
yeah
um first of all like it's good to agree
Nate I am so frustrated with the green
washing on regenerative AG today and I
can tell you that it is it's a huge
frustration to be working to try to
promote better ecological principles and
act the last 20 years and feel like
you're getting a Headway
and then you see that term co-opted in a
lot of ways that
um to me is
um inexcusable
um I think that one way of working
through that would be to have a like a
global standard regenerative agriculture
that would really the key I think that
it has to be is it has to be outcome
driven
and so often when we look at food labels
we're checking a box
um I believe in in the the premise of
organic agriculture in many ways Jimmy
I'd like to also say the the very worst
soils I've ever been on in my entire
life were organic soils in California
where they had greens and we're growing
lettuces after lettuces because they had
to till it so much right to keep the
weeds down right and so the the thing is
we put these check the box uh practices
but it doesn't yield the necessary
ecological outcomes that that we talk
about right so the fact then is that I I
definitely agree with Nick that we need
considerable emphasis on what is truly
regenerative and transparent to a
consumer I get frustrated with the
grass-fed labels that are not um very
specific
um there are opportunities that people
can add grains to those without
regulation I get frustrated with the
fact that we can bring product in from
all over the world and run it through a
USDA plant and then call it a product of
the USA
um all those Nick you and I completely
agree
um I'd also like to say and again if we
could have talked about you know a
little bit about this I understand the
confusion on on the work we did at
Whitehead and the primary thing I'd like
to say is that it all goes into the
areas that we sampled over time
and the the way that
um some of the media was done as
compared to how I decided to frame the
paper were different but it doesn't mean
either we're wrong
and the reason is is that when we went
through and did a Chrono sequence on
Will's place and again I hope you
understand how complex and challenging
it is to take all these moving targets
of land over time and try to piece
together a story I also admit the fact
that when we do these hard systems
trials we can never be like a hundred
percent like please the soil scientists
the animal scientists the crop
scientists sometimes things get a little
messy and how you work with them but the
the premise though is that what we did
is that we went in at a Time Zero and we
found land that was extracted that was
completely beat up we went to a time
three at time five a time 15 and a time
20. I think if memory serves that time
20 and this is where where the confusion
is just a quick thing sorry you average
that out right
um the all those samples you averaged it
out on the on the plot the yeah yeah I I
forget the amount of samples that were
taken we actually worked with Dr Stephen
Rosa white who is a CSU trained soil
scientist that works with General Mills
that does a great job I mean Steve's
done a lot to work with General Mills
supply chain in terms of regenerative Ag
and Steve did the work on this part
um but but but the premise though is
that the time the last period in time
when we when we sampled had only been
grazed by by cattle there was no end
part of poultry there was no pork there
had been no compost okay
manure spread
other than grazing that's it there's no
compost no nothing right and I I believe
I articulate that in the paper and and
the fact is is that from that time zero
to that point we saw 2.29 over that
period of time sequestration
and so the fact of the matter is if you
take the existing amount of cattle that
Will's running and you don't take the
impacts of pork or poultry and the main
impacts they have on soil carbon is that
they're adding nitrogen there's also
energy that we did account for energy
that comes onto the farm in the form of
grain
um that that adds that nitrogen and that
nitrogen you know Jimmy as you see you
get more nitrogen in your in your
compost in your system you get higher
metabolism you get you know things going
faster right and so the fact is if you
take his counter and you take the
sequestration value at time 20.
um that that amount of sequestration in
his stocking rate will offset it and
that's what was promoted did I
necessarily agree with the way that
everything happened on the promotion of
that I got kind of mad didn't I on some
things he would agree I didn't I didn't
like the fact the way that some of that
came out it was out of Will's control as
well it was some some corporate things
that evolved so the way that I did the
paper was different Nick and the fact is
I added the pork and poultry to make a
whole system of it and the fact is when
you have pigs and chickens to that model
the entire Farm in of itself it's also
hard to knock out a footprint on a pig
and a chicken okay from a carbon
perspective and and so the fact of the
matter is is that I I frame the paper in
a different way but it doesn't make the
claim that will made necessarily wrong
either and so it's just I think a point
of confusion that's out there if I if I
was that way I apologize but I I just
want to say that well I appreciate that
sorry just one thing well it does make
that wrong though because it's not
carbon negative beef and if you're
bringing in nutrients from off land I
know you accounted for it uh in the
study to extend but you're bringing in
feed from offland feeding it to the
monogastrics chicken and pigs and it's
spreading that manure right it's
accounted for everything was accounted
for in the LCA and it can be definitely
carbon neutral what the fact is that if
you tape a 2.29 sequestration value
okay now now let me say this you know
there's always extrapolation right and
and and I do believe in real validated
numbers right but the the fact is is
nothing is easy but if you take the
sites that have been grazed for 20 years
without any other inputs and you compare
that to the land that started is a
denuded extracted cornfield okay and you
take that over time that that with that
that number I've done the math a lot man
and and it will offset that footprint
there's no doubt it can if that if that
sequestration rate at the stocking rate
that he has it it happens and I mean we
we work six months to get that paper
published six months through peer review
I've worked others and had challenges of
course but I will also say that we're
measuring sites today that are also
building that kind of carbon as well so
I don't think it's just a one and done
by any means at all
yeah
okay and then we'll go
I would really like to see a lot more
evidence that your your net sequestering
far more than the methane that's emitted
because there's an abundance of evidence
showing that even the best systems at
most they're they're offsetting part of
it they're not necessarily bringing it
down and you also need to account for
other things that are done on the farm
that were great of course you were
planting some legumes compost uh there
is nut bearing trees like these things
all make it great you can't assign that
all to the kettle
yeah but the site that only had cattle
the point is like the sites that only
had cattle that's the sequestration rate
we reported on right so we're taking
we're taking a site right and again this
is a mosaic in time okay Farms are
complex man and all the guys that you
cite I mean I I respect them but they're
not in agriculture either many of them
right they're they're modelers they're
economists they're these other folks
they're also not funded by industry
either right so that that would be a
benefit to some extent wouldn't it like
wouldn't that skew a bit result
sometimes too and there's a lot of
Industry funding involved
yeah
so you know let's go ad hominem there
but I mean the fact of the matter is
that I mean I've I've worked my career
uh it's a publish to to take uh is
impartial of a look as I can and to make
that ad hominem claim like that I'm
getting funded by I'm not saying this is
necessarily changing your ethical
standards as a scientist I'm definitely
not saying that but but I am saying that
in response to to claiming the other
agriculture people are not allowed to
weigh in if they're if they're kind of
an ecologist as a whole and they're
scientists looking at this the space I
think they should be able to weigh-in as
well because I think they would have a
bit less of a biased perspective on the
Alternatives we're Wilding freeing up
land things like that
yeah I mean I I think it's it's a night
claim you make uh I think the fact of
the matter is that if you look at the
supporters of the the Lancet report or
you look at at all the supporters that
are looking at this research from a
plant-based perspective I think it's
it's damn naive to just talk about the
animal guys being the ones funded by Big
Industry and the fact of the matter is
that there's got to be private funding
that comes into all of this and I I
think the the fact is is that you know
there's always challenges no matter what
research you're looking at is it good to
claim and to think about that but but
what I heard was kind of a blanket
Nuance that oh well The Big Industry is
funding this and I don't agree with it
um and and so you know again going back
to that data
um I I feel that it is supported I mean
we work
um is it perfect now absolutely but
nothing is I mean I'll say that man it's
it's very hard
um but but I think likewise to sit there
and cherry pick studies you know based
on a lot of these meta models I mean
it's really hard to try to take
demonstrated farms in Real Farms that
often don't they don't the complexity
doesn't capture a man and and so I I'll
quit but but I didn't know if you wanted
to say something or what you know I do
so first of all move livestock over them
cattle or on this Farm of 2010. so all
the progress
in any impact that these old species
have had been since 2010 but that's not
my point to me that's just a fact
you know I hear these scientists argue
endlessly on the scientific method of
measuring carbon and I get that it's
because you're using reduction both
sides well who it is using reduction to
science very linear
that that was uh developed for a
laboratory situation where things can be
various precisely managed and I tell you
I have no idea how one starts to measure
carbon I have no idea I'm pretty good at
sequestering Carbon I have no idea how
to measure it but I'll tell you what I
can do you and I can go out into my
pasture with a spade a very
non-scientific instrument of spade and
we can turn it over and I can show you
that the soil looks like chocolate cake
right beside industrially farmed land it
could have been growing soy and whatever
else that you want to grow for
throw the processed foods and it looks
like compared to a good conservation
agriculture though like that's a false
comparison that's a false economy that
doesn't have to be compared right you
don't compare quality grazing like what
you're doing two industrial crops that's
that's a that's not a good comparison
well I think
I can do this
yeah yeah you did you did I've said it's
across the Spectrum the impacts and I I
think I've actually done a good job in
balancing that there's lots of good
things happening on your firm
uh there's a huge Spectrum to plant
agriculture just like there is for
grazing so yeah I I don't think you can
I don't think you can make the
comparison I I've seen uh you do a good
job will of describing how your model is
better than neighbors and your model is
better than industrial way of doing that
I think that's phenomenal how you're
describing that and how you're showing
the difference uh I I just think that
when you're comparing regenerative
agriculture animal versus plant I think
it should be a fair comparison
okay so what would be a fair comparison
then
yeah I mean you should be comparing to a
conservation agricultural system so it
doesn't need to be necessarily full
veganic but you can look back at
indigenous populations that have farmed
only crops they have not necessarily
integrated domestic animals and this
grows back a long long time this is not
just a new system of Farming veganic
Farming goes far back and I think if
you're making a comparison of say your
farm will with another firm I don't
think you should be comparing to
Industrial crop agriculture one because
most of that's really just for confined
animals a big percent of them
and two I I just think that if we're
going to be also looking at regenerative
agriculture as a whole from the plant
perspective that's what you should be
comparing to well I'll certainly try to
not do that if you please try them out
you can mix my farming industrial I
definitely don't want to do that I don't
because your farming is different
yeah and I just want to say I agree that
Will's system is now nowhere near
comparable to a conventional system so I
just want to make sure we're all on the
same page I get your regenerative
agriculture system okay so how do you
think it does compare then this is for
both of you all of you to reply the
regenerative ranching versus
regenerative plant agriculture Maybe
Will and Jason can reply first how do
you think that compares do you think
that plant regenerative plant
agriculture
um fares better or equal or do you think
uh grazing and the true regenerative
grazing the way that you're doing is
better than regenerative plant
agriculture or do we need both
yeah like I guess the way I look at it
is
um
I don't look at the output right and I
I've never really thought honestly until
when you said it I've never thought in
terms of regenerative plant versus
regenerative animal AG
I I just think of the interaction right
in in the the integration of this that
there are you know beautiful things the
room and it does like upcycling
considerable protein from inedible you
know human inedible
um plants right and it's something
that's kind of a superpower I think that
that we can take advantage of the
cropping systems
um you know the fact then is that I
don't really I I guess I just don't
choose to compare them because at the
end of the day right I care about
farmers
and the last thing I want to do is see
like a circle a circular you know firing
squad between a plant farmer and an
animal farmer and and the fact is is
that you know what I would like to see
is that
the output uh
of what's being produced
is is not not the the point of
discussion it's the management of it and
no matter what we're doing in the place
that we are at that we emphasize the
best principles we can to do the best
job of raising these things that we can
and and I think that we we're going to
come out with a lot better Solutions and
outcomes uh in terms of focusing on the
management versus the actual output of
that system
and I'd like to answer that that
Nicholas I don't think you will find
anywhere in anything I've ever written
or said or put out in which I was
critical of plant-based regenerative
agriculture nothing not a word I've
never been critical but you have been
very critical of my animal regenerative
agriculture yep that's fair again you
will be a wrestler here all right
Nicholas how do you have to reply to
that I think that's a fair point but I
I'm standing up for nature because I
know you're protecting nature to some
extent within your firm but there's no
wild carnivores that can go through
regenerative ranchings that are
replicated across the world there's not
that native ecosystem that we can return
you can do it to an extent and you've
you described that well well but this is
nothing at all personal I've seen I've
read a lot about your story I've read a
lot about your firm I think you've done
a phenomenal job there and I think
you're very smart I just think that what
I'm discussing is an idea and an idea
can be very very invasive and the idea
that we can replicate regenerative
ranching across the world there'd be
nothing worse for the the ecosystem of
wildlife that we need to restore for
Native ecosystems we're talking Wetlands
forests you can't restore full force if
you're doing regenerative wrenching uh
currently this was from a paper from Tim
searchinger uh 42 percent of of current
grasslands used as Pastor Lynn used to
be forest or Woody savannas so you can
return that but you can't do that if
you're going to be advocating for that
and like I just want to ask like because
this was a question I asked earlier but
there was not a response and I think
this would definitely put me back a bit
in like you you kind of are I'm coming
off a bit attacking I'm definitely not
attempting to be but if you're
advocating for a significant reduction
in animal sourced food production and
consumption and what's left for grazing
or the the pasture Landing the ranchers
that you know will not switch they'll
always do that switch to your model
are you advocating for a reduction in in
meat and dairy and animal Source Foods
or you think that we can meet the
current demand in the increasing demand
with this model
is neither I'm not advocating for
reduction of food of meat consumption
nor am I saying it should it should be
where it is or how I don't know where it
should be I'm saying that I want to use
my land to its highest and best use in
restarting the cycles of nature Andrew
and and someone else could choose to
make the same Choice with plant
regenerative agriculture that's fine I
support them
the amount of food we produce will be
the maximum we can produce operating
Within These cycles of nature the
abundance that spun off and the cycles
of nature are operating optimally now
that food that spun off will be made
available to Consumers it may be that
meat is too expensive for some people to
eat
and I you know I I don't want to get
into economic disparity I can't solve
that yeah but I won't uh I won't be able
to use to follow my path which is
usually my animals to restart the cycles
of nature which again is my form of
rewilding I think it's a beautiful form
of rewild
I'm happy for Jimmy and individual
farmers who use regenerative plant
agriculture to produce food on their the
land that they I won't say own but have
uh it signs control over today
we'll all produce as much food as we can
and we'll offer it to Consumers and
consumers will decide whether they're
going to eat more or less meat more or
less vegetables now I really worry about
you a dogmatic clinging to eating only
plants and how that might lead to ultra
processed plant-based protein that is
formed industrially I don't know that
you keep talking about how much meat can
we produce
farming with animal agriculture
regeneratively I don't know how much uh
food we can produce farming plant-based
uh crops peas and soybeans whatever it
was interested
but I think yeah
so I mean there's been studies on this
uh senior science writer for NASA Emily
Cassidy and others showed that growing
food exclusively for a direct human
consumption could increase available
food calories by as much as 70 percent
and feed additional 4 billion people
more than the projected two to three
billion people coming through population
growth so yeah diet change is difficult
I we can talk about that topic too uh I
don't know that we're going to go that
way I'm not dogmatic that we need every
single person to eat this way I just
think we should shift to more
plant-based diets for the planet and I'm
curious in your case Jason like are you
calling for a reduction in meat or you
think we can meet current demands
through this model
let me before you answer Jason let me
phrase the question that I have written
down here which is similar to what
you're saying Nicholas but I think it
helps the conversation so this is post
to you Jason but you guys can all reply
what would happen to the meat Supply if
the current demand for me switch to
grasp finish beef and regenerative
agriculture style Farms like white oak
pastures and we ended factory farming is
there enough land in the US or globally
to support that so go ahead there's yeah
see there's been multiple attempts to do
it uh there's been some back of the
envelope calculations
uh that that show that if if we were to
go into the land that is under crpa
and and improve the management the one
of the key challenges that in our
studies and what we've seen is that when
we Implement adaptive multi-padded
grazing we see a 30 to 40 percent
increase in productivity on the same
land
which is significant right
um and and so then the fact is is that
if we were to implement that throughout
the United States and elsewhere wear
Nick appropriate I think
um there there could be a huge
Improvement in the overall amount of
protein that is produced that way
currently
um and so from that perspective there is
a lot of opportunity to increase the
amount of efficiency productivity on on
the grass-fed cattle
um often when we look at these studies
they're just done in these very
simplified continuous grazing systems
that are low in terms of productivity
and and so I've I've worked with people
that that would indicate that that they
they do believe that we could keep the
cattle numbers fairly the same and shift
uh into
um more of a grass-faced system
but but I've never felt confident in
those numbers I've never felt really
confident saying one way or the other to
be honest with you
um and there are some massive
efficiencies that can be gained uh by
grain finishing but but the fact is is
again what I'd also like to say is that
you know most of the systems in
agriculture today are using anywhere
from 150 to 250 units of nitrogen per
acre to grow to grow plants to grow
grass
and what I'd like to say is that to me
when we talk about these numbers we're
also factoring in we have that much
fossil fuel coming in to any of these
systems
and I think those are the things that we
miss in these meta-analyzes is that what
if we were to take all that out
uh Jimmy you've done it right yet what
if you take all of that fossil fuel
whether it be a plant-based system or
crops for agriculture then things change
dramatically right on what these
outcomes look like we don't factor that
into any of these meta-analyzes likewise
again we don't factor in what's
happening with soil carbon
um and I think those are important
things that we should add and and so not
to to go around it the last thing I will
say Nick is that quite easily the best
grazing systems I've seen in terms of
biodiversity in terms of soil carbon and
management are are done in in Woodland
Savannah environments and I'm a big
advocate in many of our areas that I
think we need to get trees back back
into as many of the pastures as we can
the thing that I thought about
differently is that I'm working with
people that have cattle that have
multi-multi-generations of ranches
behind there and I can't just say we're
going to get rid of them and we're going
to re-wild it it really doesn't work
that way but what I can do is take some
of the things that you're saying that I
agree with and what does it look like if
we try to restore this into more of a
savannah or what are the ways that we
can try to get more biodiversity into
these systems and and so I don't
disagree with with what you're saying I
know Tim uh as well
um I and I and I am I am very much for
the fact that that we do need to get
these trees into our systems and finally
now hush I feel like I'm talking too
long but we also can't have this
conversation without looking at the
massive amount of the Great Planes that
was plowed up to go into corn for
ethanol and I mean we're talking
millions and millions of acres and
millions and millions of tons of carbon
that have been lost not to mention the
grassland birds that are relying on room
net migratory ecosystems and so I want
to say is that it isn't just cattle that
we that we have these troubles with
right
um I and I think that it's important to
understand that you know you look at if
the Midwest where all the all the grain
you know we know that that Michigan was
fortunate it built Chicago it built New
York built Chicago twice with with our
Pine right and and so the fact is again
I I don't think it's just a cattle
situation I think it's an agriculture
yeah I agree with a lot of that I think
biofuels are a terrible idea I don't
know why we are advocating for this in
any way I think it's I think it's
horrible um
I think it's also like important to be
clear even if we're not talking about a
veganic model we would use less
fertilizers and pesticides if we shift
to plant-based diets and the reason why
that is is there's a major major feed
conversion loss when you're turning
plants into meat most animals you're
talking about a 90 loss when you're
trying to convert growing plants
converting it into meat and this does
not have as much to do with your model
because we're talking a bit more of
chickens and pigs but like I still don't
know why we can't have commonality
around a reduction in animal Source
foods of course we should address all
the other food system issues too but I
mean okay so let's get off the beef
topic for a second let's talk about
chicken and pigs surely we can agree we
need to massively reduce the amount of
chickens and pigs that are formed
I think that that's super I think that's
super interesting Nicholas because 90 of
all animals raised in the United States
are chickens and so when we look at that
when we look at those planes where and
those are Broiler chickens those aren't
even laying hens those are Broiler
chickens and when we look at those
planes where it's just corn and soy
there's a reason why we grow that much
soy it's because it's the highest
protein Source per acre it's the highest
caloric Source per acre and so if you're
eating chicken you're basically eating
soy uh because that's what they're
getting in their diet to make them so
big so fast
go ahead will
you know for the record I'm not arguing
I'm monogastric program I'm
I'm not sure where I want to go with
that and as I pulled out earlier I've
downsized it dramatically and I'm really
unsure I I benefit my land benefits from
the animal impact of some uh hard
activities to do to give some disruption
to the land the nitrogen from chickens
and some benefit I am not arguing that
I'm live culture right now but Nick
again you just commented my account my
kind of Ruben with grain my I don't give
green to my rooms I don't believe that
yeah I'm not talking about you
necessarily well like this is a question
I guess more for Jason like I I just I
don't know why we can't find commonality
on some aspects of this uh if we're
going to be shifting into these things
like even agroforestry that you
mentioned Jason there's many many
benefits of it of course but I just
don't understand
biophysically with some basic biophysics
we cannot Farm the same amount of
chicken and pigs globally let alone the
population that's going to increase meat
consumption as they become richer so we
can't we can't do that model yeah yeah
so a couple things right so like I I
don't again I do local I do more work
right
um and you know Nick obviously you you
read a lot of papers and and and I I see
that's that's kind of your role
so you know when I when I look at these
things and I look at opportunity costs
right and you know the the white and
Hall paper and pnas would would suggest
highly differently right where they they
did their model and their model said if
we go to a 100 plant-based diet in the
United States that we only gain like
three percent on emissions
and and we have micronutrient
deficiencies right so that models in
pnas but of course you're not going to
agree with it right and and the fact is
is that everybody's got the model and
everybody can talk these numbers based
on what the who's them and you can have
your science and I can have my science
and again I you know do we need to eat
less pork or poultry I don't know but
what I do know is we can do a hell of a
lot better job in how we farm and how we
manage because what you can't convince
me of is that power already farming the
plants is going to be that big of an
improvement and and again we're also
only talking about this on a caloric
basis I think when you start breaking
this down into available Creek protein
uh when you start breaking this down
into micronutrients and other
deficiencies you know just weighing out
food is probably not the best comparison
um you know there's a recent a recent
LCA that just came out out of Roth
instead this last week that when you put
protein on a d i a s s basis an
adjustable amino acid basis you come up
with a considerably different answer
than when you look at a caloric basis on
the impacts of food and the amount of
cork uh you know the the differences in
terms of the amount of digestible
available protein on LC basis versus
calories in of itself and I don't think
it's easy to take a pound of protein
from animals and compare it to a pound
of broccoli but yet that's what the
spring of paper does right and and so I
think there's always caveats and
challenges to this that that happen
right there on the screen and paper
their LCA is it's on a weight basis you
look at their the way that they balance
out their food right and and so
um I mean like
you know so so what what should I say is
what I'm trying to get to with the fact
that you know why are we so convinced
that if we if we eat less pork or
poultry that we're gonna just inherently
understand we're gonna Farm in a better
way because what are we going to do then
are we going to replace all the soy with
turnips or like I'm just trying to track
how we're going to do that and I just
want to learn from what you're trying to
trying to say okay Jimmy you were
shaking your head so why don't you reply
to what you were going to say and then I
guess the question posed to Nicholas and
Jimmy is basically it sounds like you
you both have concerns that if there was
a shift towards more plant Foods people
eating plant Foods unless animal foods
that we would just see more of this
monocrop type of farming that you're
seeing now for plants that's your
concern it sounds like so can you guys
uh speak to that go with Jimmy first and
then Nicholas yeah and it's a great it's
an excellent point I mean somebody said
earlier that we need to change our
agricultural system in the United States
me I'm a huge advocate for making our
Farms smaller I really think that we
lost this sort of Family Farm Mom and
Pop Shop I'm I've owned two farms in my
life it's always been first one was my
first wife and I the second one in my
second wife and I and that's it we don't
have employees because we want to see
what how much we can actually physically
handle and depending on your region in
Arizona it was in Anchor just farming
plants now I did have animals that I did
raise but here it's a half an acre and
on that half an acre we produce
a custody of fruits vegetables and herbs
over a hundred different varieties for
sale for us to eat and now it's not just
turnips we grow our own dry beans we
grow our own flax we grow potatoes we
grow tomatoes we grow all the things
that you would need to store can think
of it back like
when our great grandparents were around
in the 1920s they all used to have their
farms and they all used to put up their
crops and this was a Mainstay Nicholas
even mentioned that there were
indigenous cultures and I used to live
within miles from the Hopi culture and
the Hopi culture grew corn beans and
squash and this is what got them through
the difficult times right and they
didn't grow it with manures there was no
there was no bison in the high mesas of
Northern Arizona when they were there
there were deer there were mule deer
there were pronghorn antelope they
weren't using that manure for anything
and the way that they were trying to
grow and and this is where they were
getting their protein from and their
calories from so when you ask like do we
shift to a monoculture system no
absolutely not we shift to a highly
diverse so I grow a hundred different
varieties for sale we grow over 400 on
our half acre 400 different crops and
why is that important because we're
trying to bring back the bees we're
trying to bring back the reptiles and
amphibians we're trying to bring back
the birds because like will has been
saying in his model and I don't know how
many species of grasses you're grazing
there maybe it's 10 maybe it's 15 maybe
it's 20. but when you're talking about
400 different varieties of plants that
that animals and birds and butterflies
and insects want now you're talking
about biodiversity completely in action
because we're bringing everything back
and we're doing it in a way where we're
not dominating any species at all we
don't spray we don't we don't spray when
there is an insect pressure We Don't
Spray fungicide now all of this I think
Jason said that the soil organic matter
is really bad in organic systems and it
is it's hot it's awful because they
constantly tell they replant lettuce on
lettuce and we see that in these small
micro Farms all of that needs to be
changed I am talking about a systemic
change also
I think that the model can be the more
diversity that we can produce on the
smallest amount of space and let the
rewilding happen however that we need to
do that here I couldn't graze cattle to
get my rewilding effort here I just need
to let it just do what it's going to do
and what we've seen is in the just the
nine years that we've been here now
we've got Birch forests again we have
mushrooms growing underneath the birds
Forest again we have low canopy crops
we're going to have maple trees growing
up above them in pine trees and and fur
trees that are all reproducing itself
without me touching anything just
letting it go so rewilding can happen
depending now it is sure that if a farm
has been farmed since 1866 or however
long your family has owned the farm well
it might take that long for it to come
back because if it if the farm was owned
in 1866 and the damage was occurring not
none of this is your fault I'm just
saying that if industrial agriculture
was happening and happening and
happening for a hundred years it might
take a hundred more for it to just get
back to its pre-columbian level
all right Nicholas you reply that I have
another question to move on to
I don't have a whole lot to reply I mean
shifting to plant-based diets would use
less cropland including less arable land
as well and when you're when you're
taking crops feeding it directly to
people you don't have that feed
conversion loss where if you're taking
crops especially in the case of chickens
and pigs I'm talking here still and
you're feeding it to them you're getting
a major feed conversion loss upwards of
90 percent and chickens are seen as like
obviously the most efficient way of
getting meat it's still 88 you get about
12 calories back if you give them 100.
so
um yeah in terms of like the issues with
industrial plant agriculture I also
don't like them but you'd get far less
Shifting the plant-based diets even if
you're not shifting to Jimmy's model and
I think that's a very important thing to
understand this is this is the biofixes
biophysics of what we're doing to grow
crops if you if you instead feed them to
people directly
you'd get more food and and you would
use less of the land water
crops
um cropland and and so on so I I just
think that I still can't quite
understand why we can't see that the
factory firm model that is pumping out
billions and billions of animals
I don't understand why we can't
acknowledge that that needs to be
reduced because if we're if we're
against industrial agriculture
um which I I appreciate your your major
Advocate will to say we need to get off
this model
I I don't understand why we can't admit
the confining billions of animals
feeding them crops is an efficient
system that we should extrapolate across
the world make again
that's not what we do we're in agreement
on the industrial Farm model we're on a
industrial uh animal agriculture we're
in agreement don't don't if I read that
with what I do you're doing that again
that's not what I do no I'm not saying
that's what you do I'm saying as a food
system overall I'm saying it's a food
system of a world why can't we
understand that confining billions of
animals feeding them crops and getting a
major feed conversion loss is
inefficient and we should be looking at
reducing you can say reducing a little
bit I mean I think we should reduce it
significantly for the reasons I've
showed but I I just don't I'm not
necessarily speaking to you well but I
don't understand Jason why we can't say
we need to reduce it a bit Yeah I you
know like I said I I don't think of it
in that term you know I think about it
and how we Farm I think about the
pragmatic nature of what our food system
looks like and how I can make the best
changes
um so okay I'm we're gonna reduce pork
and poultry by 20 percent
how does that work
does do we do we have our government
call call the the food system do we have
our politicians mandate it do we do like
what's happening in the Netherlands and
put dairy cows off the land
and and so so again like what I'm trying
to say is that
just because I make a statement we're
going to reduce poor compulsory
um
then
what what happens like I'd like to know
again what the what is the pragmatic
approach so to me it becomes across like
almost imperialistic that we're just
going to come in we're going to tell you
Farmers what to do and we're going to
tell you all these these entities what
what they're going to do because we want
to rewild and I just don't understand
how any of that works and and so it
doesn't make sense for me to sit there
and have this debate on we need to
reduce this or that
um under this notion that you know it's
it's going to we're just going to snap
our fingers and all this is going to go
away and all our you know we're gonna
we're gonna be on this diet and I just
don't understand it and and so I I see a
food system today in the United States
it represents nine percent of the U.S
best EPA says U.S agriculture today is
nine percent of our total emissions nine
percent
and I see a system that produces a lot
of food absolutely does it have problems
yes but just with that premise alone I'm
trying to track how all this works right
like I I don't I don't understand so
okay so I I think this is kind of a good
topic to cover uh this is obviously more
the policy area uh I am in no way
advocating for any sort of mandate any
sort of imperialist system but let's
think about okay how did the world meat
consumption quadruple since 1961 okay so
these These are stats that you can track
it's quadrupled
and that's poultry primarily I mean no
there has been a major increase in
improvements as well there's been a
decrease a little bit lately in beef
consumption you're seeing a bit of a
plateau happening in certain countries
which is great New Zealand Canada
Switzerland they're plateauing in terms
of their beef consumption and increasing
a bit of chicken so that's not so good
but I mean this is the result of of
lobbying of subsidies of marketing of
funded academics government bailing out
the major major corporations like Tyson
Cargill JBS this stuff just doesn't
happen with free will this is this is
what happens with
propping up these major major
corporations and I think that line of
reasoning you're saying is like hey what
do we do here I'm not just going to tell
people to stop uh you know firming that
or I'm not going to mandate them to stop
doing that I mean I agree but like what
are we going to do with oil and gas and
like this is obviously out of our realm
but like how are we going to get off oil
and gas how are we going to get off coal
there's ways to do it there's ways to do
it in a just transition there's ways to
do it by making the alternative more
accessible in that case it's you know
Energy Systems I think is even a bit
more complex in Food Systems but when it
comes to food like plant-based foods are
far from accessible healthy plant-based
foods are very expensive they should not
be the the cost associated with
producing most animal sourced foods and
again will don't take this as at you
because I'm not necessarily talking
about you but the the cost of producing
animal Source foods does not have all
the impacts internalized into it so how
do we create change we do these policy
shifts we make it more accessible to
make a better choice we shift subsidies
from harmful to better and the list goes
on but this is policy change and these
are things that need to happen
you should have Purdue and Tyson and
Smithfield on this debate if you want to
attack your system which is what you
keep
well I'd love for you too and don't
bother me you know I didn't I didn't
come up with this idea yeah but
you or or somebody did you invited me to
be on to argue for industrial animal
agriculture which I it's my enemy I'm
opposed to that yeah these little sound
bites where we say why can't we just
agree well you know it's just you're
putting on sound bites here that's what
you do and I know that so let's let's
talk about if I'm gonna be in this
debate let's talk about me and my system
yeah and quit going back to the other
system which you're perpetually doing
and that's why I feel like I'm being
personally attacked by you
did I just say one thing Nick
so let's say we go plant-based so what
you'll have happen
is you're gonna have Tyson JBS Purdue
and National everybody guess what
they're all going to have their
plant-based product
okay and and so the point is they're
already investing in them right they
they are
um and so the point is that like it
that system will still win right if
that's if it's a win and loss that
system will still continue okay and and
they're not going away right and so I
don't I don't see again where you look
at at that
um I think this the challenge of
industrialization the challenges that we
see with the unintended consequences
which I agree with you on
um are all going to be there still
okay
um I do want to move on a little bit to
another question that I want to ask
Nicholas and then I want to hear uh Will
and Jason reply before I do that I think
um it is really important like you said
well to preface that you're not
advocating for the standard industrial
animal farming I think what Nicholas is
trying to maybe say is to see if you
guys have common ground it sounds like
you're both against that and so that's
really really helpful for everybody
listening to know that that's not what
you both advocate for Nicholas I think
is trying to come from a place to see if
you guys can agree that even if there
was more animal agriculture shifted
towards your way of farming that it's
not sustainable to keep up the amount of
meat habits that are current
um America has and so he wanted to see
if you guys can agree with that that if
we were going to shift the majority of
our meat systems to do it the way that
will you advocate for and that you do
that we would need to reduce the amount
of meat intake that we eat it sounds
like that that's where there seems to be
some miscommunication if you guys agree
or disagree on that I don't know if you
guys want to speak on reply to that for
a second before I move on or if you
think that that's pretty good this is
exactly the main thing that I'm going at
because if we're going to replicate the
the will the the white oak pastures
model across the world we need a major
reduction in animal Source foods and
then we can have that conversation but
that's not happening anywhere there is
some of course there is some policy
people that are advocating in that way
but it's far far less than it should be
and I think if we're if we're looking at
the signs around land use
and other metrics as well then you're
going to have issues replicating that
across the world and that's why I'm
doing that that's why I'm making that
comparison
okay all right does that sound good
there before I move on
okay all right so the next question I
want to frame to Nicholas sorry I'm
losing my voice is buying local food a
way to reduce your environmental
footprint please reply Nicholas and then
Jason or will you're welcome to reply
yeah I mean this is a very common claim
uh being in the environmental space for
the last uh over a decade this is the
most kind of uh
you know go-to thing that we should do
within food we should just buy local no
matter what it is and I think that kind
of steers away from the overall impacts
you see with the overall food system uh
you know 80 of the the the footprint
from the environmental footprint as a
whole is from land use so like
deforestation ecosystem degradation and
and firing so the emissions from animals
farming equipment fertilizers
you know less than 10 overall is from
transportation in the case of beef it's
one percent so of course there's many
reasons to support local you know where
the food is you know the farmer is
better for the economy better to support
the community but in terms of just you
know the overall environmental picture
buying local is not necessarily the
first thing we should be doing I think
we should shifting more towards
plant-based diets
go ahead
so I agree that just because it's local
does not mean it's good okay
spam and Pepsi and Cheetos or local
somewhere
but I hope you will agree with me that
centralized industrialized agriculture
absolutely has impoverished Rural
America
the money doesn't stay here anymore
the money goes to Wall Street or Silicon
Valley or whatever else the money does
not stay here if industrial centralized
agriculture has rendered Rural America
to be economically irrelevant nobody
needs it and if you think that's a good
thing then that's that's fine I don't
know I agree with you there and I
achieve that that expands beyond the
United States as well the the the the
rural situation is an issue and I think
there's an opportunity to to have it
rewilding there and and like there's no
incentive for people that own several
acres of land rurally to keep a forest
to keep the native ecosystem that was
there there's more money for them to cut
that down sell it and start ranging and
I think that's an issue
uh you know I am a Rancher I'm working
in a great director and I employ 180
people and we write payroll checks in
this building every Friday for over a
hundred thousand dollars in Clay County
Georgia if you're looking up you'll see
it's one of the poorest counties in the
United States of America
but that wasn't where I was going that's
true that's not where I was going and I
will say this has gone from a ghost town
to a very nice little destination if you
don't believe it come and look
but that again uh that that wasn't my
point I want to talk about the
resilience of the food supply
so the big companies it sounds like you
advocate for
how for for it I mean it sounds like it
but uh you know for so many years
the only metric that was important was
efficiency and law and cost of goods
lowering cost of goods efficiency
incredibly vertical system that is very
fragile and we've seen the fragility in
the pandemic we've seen it in the storms
it's an economic situations
these small local food systems offer so
much resilience as compared to the I'm
not saying that it's not incumbent upon
me to be efficient it is it is I'm
obvious efficient I can but efficiency
is not the only metric I measure
yeah I think that's super interesting
because me I've also spent pretty much
my entire life in rural areas both in uh
Apache County not in Idaho that was the
neighboring County Apache County Arizona
and now I'm in uh the Utah way County or
Pepino here in uh Walla where we have
maybe 400 people living in our town and
we're in the middle of a food desert uh
as we were in Arizona as well so if it
wasn't for small farms going to Farmers
Market having farm kiosks whatever then
there would be no such thing as fresh
produce well the process a food desert
they don't even Define a food desert in
Canada unless you're in a city if you're
in a rural area they say okay well if
you're within 10 kilometers well our
closest place to find good food is about
30 kilometers away for 17-18 Miles so
this is this is too much for we have a
big senior population here so I
completely agree that what we need to do
is bring back those local farms and I I
am very impressed with the amount of
people and what you've done in Clay
County I I just think that's impressive
um because to be able to employ 180
people in a really really small town uh
and everybody has food on their table
and it's become a nice destination space
I think that's straight I think that's
great I think what Nicholas said is
super interesting I think that we can
make our farms in places like this now I
have an interesting situation with a
biologist the other day where he told me
that we need to keep killing deer now
I'm not a hunter and I don't believe in
hunting but we need to keep killing deer
because they're eating the forest
because we killed all the wolves that
used to eat the deer and if we don't
kill the deer then they're going to eat
the forest however interesting point
however we let regenerative agriculture
this is what these people are calling
themselves run pigs in those same
forests
without without any without any uh
reason other than just because they want
to start raising pigs for me but they
want to kill the deer but raise the pigs
in the exact same Forest
I think I think we have a problem when
we're talking about regenerate
Agriculture and it's definitely
go ahead yeah yeah thanks so I you know
Nick it occurred to me we were talking I
you know something hit me and I think
at the end we both want to make
improvements in land and in people and
it it kind of just you know hit me that
coming out of you know maybe in a good
place but from different ways
and I I guess where I've I've spent my
career
is that I work with farmers
and I'm on the ground as much as I can
we we've got a new big project we're
working with 60 different sites
throughout the US
and I care about Rural America and I
care about people and I know you do too
and the the the the the challenges I've
seen like where our site is in in rural
Michigan 80 to 90 percent of that area
in rural Michigan the kids are on a
school lunch program
and I think we can all speak to the
quality of food that is probably in that
system
and I've seen this massive extraction
of rural wealth and well-being in my
career
today the farmer gets 11 cents of the
food dollar at the farm gate in the
United States
and the the lens I've come at that you
know is when I go and talk to a farmer
Jimmy about regenerative AG or you know
hey thinking about implementing these
soil Hill principles I often get a blank
look
and it would be no different if I were
to go into downtown wherever and find a
young impoverished person and say you
know what if you invest in the stock
market you're gonna be a lot better off
and they look at me like I'm crazy like
they have no concept of what I'm talking
about and that's the same problem in the
same challenge I I get in Rural America
today because the the land managers and
the people I work with every day are
hand them out
they can have land they can have
Machinery uh they can have equity in
that but they still have massive cash
flow issues they're dependent upon the
banks they're dependent upon these
challenges
and the way I've tried to work with that
is to help them from a standpoint of
getting more ecological resilience
thinking about how to to make their
lands better and more profitable we
haven't talked about profit hardly at
all today
and that lens is how I've come through
right it's like can we do a better job
with what we have and where we are
and that's just the way I've chosen to
do these things I don't like to get in
these big Global debates on what this
looks like I just care about my
community and where I'm at I've seen
will start it when I first met Willie at
30 employees
and now he's over 100 he said 180.
and and that shows the multiplier
effects of a food system
that we don't capture an environmental
footprint that we don't capture in a
carbon footprint and and so at the end
of the day I I think I can I can
acknowledge like many of the challenges
Nick said today with biodiversity with
with the fact that we have degraded land
for agriculture
um and and the fact is is that
for me instead of having these big like
thought experiments on what to eat and
how to do this throughout the world it's
just starting at a local basis and
working with people and seeing if we can
create change and create concentric
circles outside of that change to make a
bigger impact for the Ecology of the
system
and so what I will say Nick is I don't
disagree with many of the things that
you're saying it's just I've chosen to
come at it in a way that I see more
tangible improvements in my small career
and window on the land with the people I
work with great okay Nicholas go ahead
and reply and then I have a perfect
question for you Nicholas to what they
have to say go ahead Nicholas
well I don't have a whole lot to reply
to that I think that's a good way of
putting it we are looking at from
different lenses uh I think we have lots
of commonalities I think that uh we can
look at it from both the global
scientific analysis and the local level
and the socioeconomic challenges and
also on the back end we can look at the
impacts of not addressing biodiversity
not addressing climate change to the
level we should and what would happen
socioeconomically in that way so I think
we can look at it both I don't think we
we need to focus on it and that's not
saying that it's not valid to focus on
it's just a local level because it can
be very helpful to many I just think we
need to have both lenses great so I have
a question specifically for you Nicholas
you advocate for a significant reduction
in animal Foods in the population's
diets to help the environment but is it
unrealistic to expect people to reduce
their mean Dairy intake that much and
can the White Oak pastures model be good
enough because it does improve the
environment on many levels like soil
regeneration so how come that can't be
good enough to basically what they're
saying because you're seeing things on a
micro on your own level getting in the
dirt and then you're advocating for
instead for like a big meat reduction
how come what they're doing isn't good
enough
yeah I I in terms of like him not doing
enough I don't think uh that's an issue
I think Will has done a ton uh my my
issue overall is that we can do many
things to shift towards further
plant-based diets integration of maybe
70 of diets plant-based culturally
relevant across the world there's been a
number of analyzes to make that relevant
no matter where you're in the world
Elance has done a ton of that analysis
and in terms of like the the financial
analysis of different organizations
working on that
it is a fraction a tiny fraction of the
subsidies and financial institution
grants going towards a shift towards
plant-based diet as it is towards an
overall animal Source diet or to the big
companies so I don't think that's a fair
comparison
um yeah so in terms of like how do we
feed the world this is what we need to
be thinking of uh if we're looking at
replicating this across the world then
we need to think okay this is great is
this going to allow rewilding is this
going to allow
wild ecosystems to return is this going
to allow us to protect 30 percent of
land by 2030 and uh with the land
analysis alone but also some other ones
as well that will not do that okay great
um I just have a few more questions I
want to ask and I want to bring the
topic just a little bit more clear about
methane so if you could talk Jason or
will on your thoughts about
um the issues within that within the
regenerative model and then I want to
bring it next after that to the other
other factors like biodiversity and soil
health and animal waste even and water
use so let's go there just real quick we
we've been measuring enteric methane
real validated data not models
uh for 12 years
uh we we do that through different
scientific methods
um I can tell you that any way that you
measure enteric methane is a challenge
and there's always challenges with
respect to meeting voluntary feed intake
uh with the with the scientific you know
you're running animals through a shoot
or you know doing things like that
um and and what I can tell you on the
small level
is that when we generally use ipcc tier
two equations in our system where I'm at
they often can overshoot
um methane by 15 to 20 percent often
that's because of the digestibility of
the forge maybe if I I should start you
know methane is a byproduct of forage
digestion in the room
uh basically it it's it's a way of
binding free hydrogens in the rumen it
is 98 is a rotated two percent goes out
the back end
uh the methane is in the environment for
normally about 10 to 12 years it is
hydroxylated by OHS into CO2 and height
in in water
um methane has been fairly constant we
think uh for a very long period of time
we've had ruminants on Earth for 56
million years
um the methane numbers begin to go up
based on the the science I read uh in
the industrial revolution
um during that time we've not seen in
the U.S numbers we've not seen increases
at all in the amount of ruminants that
we have but we've seen considerably
higher emissions of enteric methane
pardon me of methane not interior of
methane atmospherically often
um what that would probably lead to
would be the the other industries that
are bringing non-biogenic sources of
methane into the atmosphere I.E fossil
fuels and and so effectively then what
has happened
um if you look at the data from the last
10 years example for EPA uh we've seen
decreases in enteric methane from cattle
in the United States uh based on those
numbers
and and so effectively then
um I mean we can go in I I don't know
how much you want to go into it
um but but what I would like to say is
that methane is this this system has
been happening for a very long period of
time without significant changes in
limited animals globally and and the
fact then is that there are other
sources that are leading to considerably
greater amounts of methane that are now
in the atmosphere today again it's part
of a natural cycle that's been happening
a very long time yeah so I think we can
go back and forth on this a little bit I
think there's some good discussion we
can have here so um yeah I've studied
nothing extensively too uh methane as a
whole uh as a as a broad topic it's
resulted in anywhere from a quarter to
even a half of warming to date and of
course there's other sources of methane
besides enteric fermentation oil and gas
natural gas in particular is a major
source globally the number one source of
human cause methane is livestock it is
catalog now you can say that it's been
like cattle herd numbers have been
somewhat steady for a period of time
uh but if you go back far enough you can
see a massive hockey stick uh curve up a
ruminant firm ruminant numbers that have
also contributed significantly to
methane into warming now throwing the
other way around if we reduce herd
numbers we can significantly reduce
methane quickly and really all methane
we should be addressing all methane
quickly and the reason is because if we
reduce all CO2 today which we need to do
ASAP we need to decarbonize our Energy
System
but if if we don't address methane we're
not going to address the the short-term
opportunities to lower our climate
change impacts to lower atmospheric
warming and by doing that we can
hopefully avoid some of the climate
feedback loops we're going to face now
in terms of like biogenic methane uh I'm
going to challenge that a bit back and
perhaps we can have a discussion on it
I've seen many of the the brightest
climate scientists in the world describe
that methane is methane no matter the
source and I've pulled tons and tons of
ipcc reports and have direct quotes I
don't buy at all the methane from cattle
is perfectly a part of the carbon cycle
I think this is misinformation by some
is disinformation it's directly to
support a certain cause definitely not
saying that in your case Jason but I
think that
it's flawed and I'm going to tell you a
while I'll talk about a little bit about
the studies that show this so when you
talk about methane going up in the
atmosphere
from cattle
uh it doesn't just convert into CO2 and
then get sequestered back in the grass
only one to two percent of it breaks
down into CO2 the rest as long as
methane is is rising globally heats the
planet at about 80 times over 20 years
so if you reduce that quickly you're
going to see a major reduction and you
know this is there's direct quotes from
ipcc describing this so a small fraction
of CH4 emissions is oxidized in the
atmosphere to CO2 and H2O before
deposition with the fraction depending
on the location and timing of emissions
so to say it's perfectly a part of the
carbon cycle and the biogenic methane
doesn't matter I don't buy that at all
and neither does the ipcc reports and
they've of course they've categorized it
a bit differently recently in terms of
fossil methane and biogenic methane but
you can look at those figures and
they're a couple difference we're
talking 80 or 79 for for methane from
biogenic sources and 82 from fossil
sources so they're factoring in this
within that so the narrative that
methane from from cows doesn't matter I
don't buy and then if you're talking
about like the historic situation of of
bison and how there was a lot of them
this is a whole different story this is
you're comparing wild native animals to
domesticate animals major ecological
differences which I think we've already
talked about at the start of this
conversation but even in terms of
methane there's a lot of uncertainty a
lot of these ruminants in the past too
they made a defer less methane and
there's also research that shows they
did have an impact on warming but of
course pre-industrialization we had a
buffer we could have some and we would
never want to take away native ruminants
from a wild ecosystem because they net
provide way more benefits when they're
natively in the right place
so okay let's let's wrap that up so I
can let them respond I'll leave it there
yep
yeah
yeah I mean I guess we're just going to
disagree on the the way to analyze these
numbers Nick and the fact that you know
again if you just you know you threw the
60 number out there and again I mean you
look at in the United States only about
three percent of the United States
footprint is nothing okay and and from
enteric animals right and and the fact
then is that you know this has been
happening forever
and and um we only have seen these rises
in methane since Industrial Revolution
and we know that there was considerably
greater megaphone there okay and and so
the fact then is that also the ipcc does
Define biogenic and it does Define inter
methane as part of a biogenic as a cycle
that is not contributing additional CO2
into the environment it's it is in a
circular way it doesn't say that I would
like to see that because I I've I've
sourced I've been finding biogenic what
is biogenic methane what is biogenic is
more than just cattle biogenic is also
natural sources too
but but it's in a circular way right not
necessarily biogenic does not mean it's
a circular way bio biogenic means it's
not coming from deep underground from
fossil fossil sources right but that
doesn't mean that the methane doesn't
impact the atmosphere
yeah it is an additional source so so
the fact then is that to me like if if
you have this system
um it's been happening a very long time
right and so you know to to throw out
like the fact that you know
the uh TNC comes out with the report
just recently indicating they think that
we're overestimating uh the global
warming potential methane four-fold
um I we're working on a data set that's
in review right now that would suggest
tenfold uh based on the half-life of
methane and based on its global warming
potentials and the fact then is that
these are all models again right we're
taking data that's hard to measure and
then we're trying to expound it into
these large debates
um but when the TNC publishes papers
like that I I tend to think that that's
a pretty non-biased source and and so we
can agree to disagree in in terms of
that
um what I will say is that we can always
do better as grazing managers to lower
that footprint through our management
um I'm not as a big believer in all the
technologies that are discussed
um but and I also finally say is that
when we do think about a methane in a
shorter Half-Life what what also becomes
a problem is that there is considerably
greater methane coming off manure in in
feed yards and dairies and other
confined situations and because of that
short-term nature of it it becomes a
much greater problem and if you have
looked at the National Data over time
we've seen uh manure methane go up
significantly while enteric methane is
actually based on EPA data has come down
so we can't have our cake and eat it too
and the fact is is that there are
considerable problems that we're seeing
with with methane coming off manure and
and that's something that has to
definitely be addressed
okay should I move on to the next
question or Nicholas do you want to
reply to that yeah I'll just say quickly
regarding EPA there's a number of
situations where EPA is saying that
methane is an urgent situation we need
to reduce it any sort of you know
conversation around the low greenhouse
gas figures of a national scale I think
there's so much Nuance missing from that
conversation if you're just talking
about direct greenhouse gases uh in in a
country that emits a huge amount then
that's going to skew the numbers a
little bit if you're not factoring how
much carbon you can draw down from the
atmosphere in terms of land opportunity
costs then that skews that number
different too and if you're measuring
methane over 100 years or you could
instead measure it over
a 20-year period like it's happening in
New York right now then you're also
going to get a far different number but
I mean perhaps that's a longer
conversation but in terms of like low
National greenhouse gas figures for
different Industries there's a ton of
nuance there
agreed I think one of the big challenges
I've been frustrated with is like the
fertilizer industry and the fact is is
there's been considerably greater
methane coming out of those systems
based on drone reports and other things
that's what's actually being reported
um so
what I will say though is that I do
believe we can do a better job in
managing methane in our production
systems
um I I don't believe that the the bovine
the grazing bovine is as causal of a
factor of the the atmospheric numbers
that we're discussing all right so agree
to disagree it sounds like with this
um can you then Jason and will speak now
on the soil Health you spoke a little
bit about that how regenerative animal
farming improves the soil how does it do
in regards to biodiversity animal waste
uh water use erosion yield Etc
we we've done chronology on Will's place
from a standpoint of soil microbial
health and if you look at starting from
again an extracted acre of cropland
and follow it through the system you see
exponential Improvement in indicators
like water extracted organic carbon and
nitrogen
um you see considerably greater active
carbon uh you see improvements in
organic matter
um that can happen in a quote-unquote
regenerative plant system it can happen
uh generally speaking
um you know the the infiltration that we
typically see in these systems as you
build more organic matter you go more
poor space you go more soil aggregate
there's more areas for water to
infiltrate and that keeps the system
resilient we can do that in any system
agriculturally it doesn't again it's a
principle of soil Health it isn't a
practice that can only be done in a
certain system
um you know as far as you know the areas
if you want to take it in a in a in a a
standpoint of what we've seen and
measured I mean all those indicators
have gone up significantly from a
standpoint of improvement
yeah let me talk on that too Ellen that
so we're talking about
plant-based agriculture now and that's
what I've seen too I took a piece of
land where the old owner scraped the top
12 inches of topsoil sold it off to make
the road to the house now I didn't
realize this when I bought the place I
had no idea that's a bad deal yeah it
was it was awful so when I started I was
pretty I was pretty excited sticking my
hand in the soil and realizing how far
down it went it was really sandy loam
kind of spongy almost peedy we're up
here in a glacial a glacial uh drift off
and so we're kind of we have that peat
in our soil as well
but the acid level was 5.1 I couldn't
grow a harvestable vegetable crop to
save my life and when I put a cover crop
in like buckwheat it didn't even grow
like it
it's hid there so I also had to find
ways to bring it in now I was not going
to because I was newly vegan in 2014 I
wasn't going to bring in animal
byproducts I wasn't going to bring in
manure I just was going to try and do it
with just regenerative plant-based
products and what we could get around
here was straw and Chip Branchwood and I
don't know if you know of Chip
Branchwood this was actually developed
in Quebec uh at the University at the
University of Laval and they were trying
to figure out a way to use sort of like
the byproduct of the forestry industry
and what they were coming up with were
these like really small branches that
they couldn't log into Lumber or turn
into whatever other kind of wood product
and so they chipped it and they realized
that the carbon to nitrogen ratio of
this particular chip Branchwood was like
70 to 75 to one whereas wood chips are
115 to 120 to 1. so it's super green it
was already it was it was very fungal in
its aspects as opposed to a bacterial
kind of system right so what they did is
for about 18 months they would let this
all decompose and in a matter of 18
months it would turn into a carbon to
nitrogen ratio of like 16 to 1 or 20 to
1 and it was just oh you're rock star
then yeah yeah exactly exactly so we
thought about that and we said okay so
we're going to bring in some of that
ship Branch because here around here
they have to cut around the power lines
all the time right otherwise when we
have the big windstorms and the
rainstorms it's just going to fall on
the power lines and everybody's going to
be in trouble so they call them kind of
tree surgeons right and so they would go
ahead and ship all this and we would
just get it delivered here for basically
nothing
and we would mix that with green grass
from our strips in our Fields so when we
would create our half acre which was a
downsloping system as opposed to a
Terrace system because here we have so
much water during the rain during the
planting season that in a terror system
really the beds would just float so in
our permanent bed system we kind of let
it shift go downhill but instead of
letting it go all the way downhill to
the to the creek that was below so we
would lose all our nutrients we would
create green strips in between all the
all the rows of beds so they would just
collect if any compost would come off it
would collect any dirt that would come
off would collecting those green strips
and it would just flourish like the
grass would just go crazy so I would go
and cut it back a little bit mix that in
with the chip Branchwood and that would
create our compost and because that
grass is basically 25 to 1 mixed with
that chip brand so at a 75 to one well
there you go you got your almost perfect
compost ratio of 40 to One's best I
think we we were at like 47 to one right
so this is what we use to build our beds
completely regenerative happens all the
time trees grow all the time Grass Grows
all the time we even Incorporated
chipped leaves or or shredded leaves
because they're here all the time also
we leave a nice layer all over the place
and we decide to mix that into so it
wouldn't compact well from that 2016
soil test
we had a soil the soil organic matter
was still pretty good because of that
peat it was 5.2 the pH was 5.1 we
weren't going to be able to grow much
seven years later we're at 7.2 soil
organic matter and our pH is 6.9
so obviously everything now just grows
now this is completely plant-based just
using regenerative materials everything
coming within 15 to 20 miles originally
I did buy compost because we didn't have
the we didn't have the knowledge yet of
the people who we could get all the
materials from so I bought a what they
call a live mulch compost which is
basically the same thing it was a little
bit further away and we used that but
since 2021 we haven't been we haven't
bought anything more in now because of a
kind of a catastrophic event that
happened last year we lost one of our
Fields completely because there was so
much rain and such a period of time that
it stayed saturated from May until
November and it just kept raining and
raining I mean we must have had I don't
know
300 300 350 millimeters of rain so I
don't even know how many inches that is
20 24 inches of rain
um in just the growing season so we lost
an incred an entire field we just
couldn't even plant it it was impossible
so I was like well wait a minute what if
I do a test now if I'm getting if I'm
getting that grass but I want more grass
I want more hay what if I seed Alfalfa
with all the native Flora that's coming
back all the yarrow all the dandelion
all the
um all the Clover all the red clover all
the white clover that's growing in there
what if I seed Alfalfa too in that well
when nothing really else would grow even
the native flower because it was too wet
the Alfalfa proliferate right so the
Alfalfa grew really tall and now at the
end of the season is sort of dry dried
out a little bit now you have this
native Flora mix of like 15 16 17 plants
so now we cut we're going to cut that
and we're going to make our compost so
now I'm trying to understand and
research because we're a research Farm
as well trying to understand how much
land we actually need within a
plant-based system
to create the compost that we need to
fertilize our beds because we are
obviously needing that compost to grow
those veggies and I'm pretty sure we're
going to come to a ratio of one to one
one say one acre of land is necessary to
be to act as comfortable ingredients for
one acre of edge so a one to one ratio
um I'm gonna pose this question to
Nicholas and then I have one question
for you Jason
um Nicholas you seem quite negative on
your social media about Alan Savory and
the Savory Institute what makes you an
expert in this area have you been on
holistically managed ranches have you
been to Mr savory's demonstration site
or have you researched them can you just
kind of explain a little bit about that
then I have one question for you Jason
and will and then we'll finish up
I've had since I was young a major
distaste for disinformation and
exaggerated claims and there's nothing
personal against Allen Savory here but I
have used him as an example because he's
not just a one-off figure he he is
really the leader of holistic grazing of
regenerative agriculture he's been
studying this for a long long time of
course and and really is the go-to
person so
um I think it's totally fair to critique
the ideas that he's putting forward so I
have not drank the Allen Savory Kool-Aid
I think there's a number of reasons why
there's issues with this I mean you can
look at countless countless
meta-analyzes of the claims that he's
made and I don't think their claims that
any of us here would necessarily make
that you can reverse climate change with
grazing that you can reverse
desertification there's just not nearly
enough evidence to back that up and in
fact the evidence is pointing the
opposite way and uh I mean if you're
looking at
a meta-analysis on say biodiversity this
is also a big part too 109 independent
studies showed that removing grazing
from Land across all animals livestock
exclusion increase abundance and
diversity and a big part of the topic
with with Savory is you know arid
Landscapes and you know virtually
desertified areas so to reverse this
through verification but similar
comparisons have looked at this
comparison
and shows that ecosystems with extremes
and low temperature or high temperature
can particularly be impacted by grazing
which can further damage soil
characteristics reducing already limited
plant biomass and decreasing animal
diversity so the claims being made that
have been very popularized by his Ted
Talk
um have just been in many ways
exaggerations now I'm not saying that
everything that he's done is bad of
course there's been some good parts but
I think when you're looking at not only
the the meta-analyzes on the topic and
what they say but also
you can even look a bit to his history
to see that there's a number of
challenging things that should make you
be skeptical of him as a leader to your
movement
um his background is a white nationalist
military leader and there's been
countless issues of that some of these
things he's admitted to to being wrong
on killing 40 000 elephants thinking
that would save the environment he's
admitted to being wrong in that case
um but then to go the other stream and
say grazing is going to cure all the
problems I just think those types of
exaggerations lack Nuance lack
complexity have the ability to lead to
greenwashing lead to people championing
you as a as a way to promote business
interests and I don't I think that's a
just a major trickery and uh you know
nothing against him personally I've had
discussions with him back and forth uh I
open I welcome more discussions because
every time I talk to people that have
different opinions than me I always
learn something I welcome that I might
be wrong in some of these things but I
think that making exaggerated claims
like grazing can reverse desertification
climate change and cure the planet not
enough evidence not even close enough
evidence to back that up
okay go ahead uh Jason reply and then I
have a question for you
so Nick have you ever have any of these
ranches I don't think I need to be on
one of the ranch to have an independent
analysis and compare the scientific
analysis that's happening across the
world on this have you been Have You
Been
are you allowed
hold on let's let Jason reply yeah go
ahead yeah the answer is none of the
people writing these papers and and the
fact is that is that when you get on
these sites okay
see the differences in terms of
management
and I I think if Alan got anything wrong
was he was talking about grazing and I
agree I think that's the wrong claim to
me but but what I would like to say is
that the Nuance of Land Management
that Alan is brought to the table in
terms of bringing in the understanding
of working with managers on managing the
ecosystem processes across complexity
um Allen was was walking barefoot in the
bush you know in the 1940s okay
and in the most observant person now do
I agree with a lot of the things out
there Nick no
but what I'd also like to say is that
when you are out there and you see the
differences in terms of management
between people that are holistically
managing versus those that are the the
contrast is is immense
and I I can tell you I've been on sites
that they have worked with the Savory
Institute has worked with in Africa
that had many many challenges one of
which was the the Wayne G people Group
which is outside of Victoria Falls and
they fought desertification in their
Landscapes because they were over
grazing and the key isn't the grazing
it's the management of the grazing and
I'll never forget the fact is there's a
river uh the susenda river that runs
right parallel to their landscape
and they had been practicing this way
now for like 10 years and that River
normally dries up pretty rapidly into
the dry season
and to talk to the women there the women
are the ones gathering firewood they're
the ones walking to get water every day
up to five miles
and as they began to improve their
management and allowing for appropriate
recovery in Savannah grasslands those
lands began to regenerate the water
began to infiltrate versus run off and
that River began to become more
perennial over time
and the fact is is we can read all the
meta-analyzes they want but when you
look into the eyes of a woman from
Africa that doesn't have to walk five
miles to get water anymore because their
lands are improving based on management
that means something
and so the fact is we can make the
claims we want to make but I think a lot
of this again leads to being on the land
working with people from a social
Dynamic and understanding how management
changes Landscapes okay just really sure
apply Nicholas because I want to last
the last question to Jason
go ahead
foreign
Ty have done an incredible job
reading and memorizing an enormous
quantity of a search work
I don't think you've ever regenerated
much degraded land
I think it's an act of incredible
arrogance for you to decide this study's
good this was not this one suits me this
one doesn't you know I think it's an act
of incredible privilege for you to
decide how people who've been on the
land all their life should manage that
land and what the people should eat that
are buying the production from because
I'm I'm Blown Away by that arrogance
Improvement I mean I just wanted to have
some some peer-reviewed scientific
evidence of these anecdotal claims that
are made I don't think that's coming
from a place of privilege I don't think
that's coming from a place of elitism in
fact I think there's an abundance of
research money going towards justifying
animal sourced Foods in a number of
different ways so I've challenged Alan
Savory on this
peer review published that he claims
that's reductionist science I think
anecdotal claims about what you see on
the land can be just as reductionist if
not more so and I also think that back
to the claim about improving low income
uh women who also are working the land
there's many ways we can do that and
that's a very complex topic and to claim
that grazing is this is a solution there
I think there's a lot of complexity
missing from that statement and I think
that's used in a way to pull at the
heartstrings to justify this this
business that is destroying ecosystems
across the world so you can say that I'm
coming at this from a level of arrogance
certainly not my intention
um I understand that independent
scientific analysis is important I think
we all agree on that I think it's
important to not cherry pick I've
compiled what what I think is likely the
largest database on different reasons to
shift to plant-based diets this is not
cherry picking data this is a massive
massive library of the reasons why we
should do that it's not just environment
if it was just environment we'd probably
be looking at like maybe like a a 90
plant-based diet but if you look at
Health you look at pandemic risk you
look at antibiotic resistance then this
picture makes it very clear that we
should be shifting towards plant-based
lights
okay so I just have one final question
for you Jason and then you guys can make
your closing statements if that sounds
good
um Jason you have uh mentioned Alan
Savory as a leader in this space in
previous like podcasts and stuff so do
you support it sounds like maybe you
don't but do you support his claim that
holistic grazing can reverse climate
change where he stated Alyssa grazing
with lower greenhouse gas concentrations
to pre-industrial levels in a matter of
decades this was in the Savory 2013
report do you agree with that claim
I think
managing holistically
can
reverse the wrongs that we're dealing
with today
and I think that that's perhaps
different from just using grazing
grazing's a tool in a toolbox
but I think that managing holistically
and what I mean by that is trying to
account for the ecological
the um the ecological uh the economical
and the social dynamics of our world in
the short long term simultaneously
can indeed Rectify those challenges
Allen has brought considerable thought
into that debate
um he got that from many other people
you know that that have been been
through from you know uh you know smuts
to voice on
Aristotle and others okay so so I think
that you know these these Concepts when
we went from Aristotle to Descartes I
think we had a lot of problems
and I think that that what happens in
these scientific debates is it's so
difficult to account for that complexity
and and that that's what I'd like to say
and and the fact is that um
there there is a lot of positives that
I've seen brought to Land Management
globally
um and people I am honored to work
shoulder to shoulder with and I've seen
that that that confirm that okay so to
final uh close us out if you could spend
just like 30 seconds not too long on
like a final statement if there's
anything else you want to say to finish
off this conversation well why don't you
go first and then Jason and then I'll
have Jimmy and nicholasco
yeah I'd like to say that I am enclosing
I am certainly not in opposition to
regenerative plant-based articles I
think it's one
uh I am not an advocate of centralized
industrialized commodity farming on the
animal side or the plant inside I'm in
opposition to it
and I'm going to say that I am a uh
studied practitioner of this form of
agriculture and for
me at this time this place
this ecosystem this economy this works
well for my family for my employees for
my community for my animals and my land
and I'm grateful for the opportunity to
be able right thank you great glad Jason
um thanks thanks for the opportunity
um I'm not sure you know if we've moved
the needle in any regard that Nick Jimmy
good to meet you and to hear your your
thoughts and
um you know just closing every day I try
to be humble and I've been working on
land for a majority of my career
and every day the longer I live and the
longer I do I feel like the less I know
and that's in a way just to honor the
complexity of land and people and
livelihoods
and my argument I guess or my my premise
is that
I think that the tangible in front of me
that I can help make a shift on the
landscape through approved management
regardless of the system every day
uh empowers you know my want to and my
spirit to try to improve the livelihoods
of people
and I am I'm thankful for that
opportunity to to be able to work and to
do these things I want to give honor to
the other opinions
um I have many dear friends that are
vegetarian that I I publish with I work
with I love them dearly
um and and so you know I just want to
give thanks for the opportunity and um
enjoyed it great thank you so much
Nicholas why don't you go ahead
um yeah I think uh I've learned some of
this discussion that have been very
helpful I think uh we have a lot of
commonalities I think if we focus on
that in the regenerative agriculture
movement it would be great I don't like
the polarization of things I think there
is opportunities to uh have regenerative
plant agriculture just as much as a part
of that conversation
the reasons I think I've made clear I
think we need to give far more land Back
To Nature and I think we need to give
far more land back to Native wildlife
and native plants and I ultimately don't
see how that's possible with scaling up
ranching and I also don't see how that's
possible without calling for a reduction
of animal sourced Foods so uh I also
stay humble I could be wrong in some of
these things I I appreciate that there's
lots of complexity to this I think uh
none of these decisions should be made
from an ivory Tower I think we should
have independent scientific analysis
from the local level and at the global
level looking at what happens when you
make changes
ultimately like I think we can agree I
think we should have far more access to
healthy plant Foods at uh good prices uh
because that's going to be good for the
planet good for ourselves and there's no
reason people should not have access to
healthy foods so I think doing that I
think there's a commonality there and I
think if we work towards that within our
other things we're working on I think
that would be a big win okay can you
make your final statement Jimmy I guess
I have to say that everything that I've
seen in my years of also having my hand
in the earth and the soil and I'm also a
naturalist so I want to see uh the whole
world come back before the humans
dominated this planet and and I do
respect the way that you manage things
down there will I do
um and if all ranchers Ranch like you do
we might be having a whole different
world by now but I'm just afraid that
that's not gonna happen people aren't
going to listen to you all the time as
they're not going to listen to me all
the time but I can push
for a completely plant-based agriculture
future I can help transition those
Farmers away from an animal agriculture
future so that they do stay on the land
I believe we need more Farmers but I
don't see it from an animal exploitation
and animal suffering issue I I can only
see it now from a way of growing plants
by using plants and for that I think
we're going to be able to benefit our
planet and for all beings that we share
okay thank you so much everyone for
being here I really appreciate the
humility it takes to come on and have
this conversation and we're going to end
it here thanks everyone for tuning in
great
foreign
[Music]